- Drip!
(Joey screaming)
- Trash Taste has drip now.
- Let's go, you can get your
very own Trash Taste merch now.
- We have promoted Apari
a ton on this channel
and we love their clothes.
We love it so much that we decided
we'd partner up with them
and make some Trash Taste/Apari merch.
- Hell, yeah!
- [Connor] Look at that, look at that.
- God I love that design so much.
- Oh my God, so we have the normal,
I am wearing the regular
Trash Taste design
and Garnt over there,
is wearing the After Dark design.
- [Garnt] I've got the after dark version.
- Ohh.
- So cute
But don't worry if you're
living in a hot area,
we also have t-shirts as well
look at Connor wearing his beautiful.
- Lavender one.
This is my personal favorite,
my recommendation
- It looks very nice.
- We literally needed
to get this custom dyed
to get Trash Taste purple.
- That Trash Taste
purple design, so clean.
- But if you need something
a little more cozy,
you're thinking like you
wanna get a bit warm.
Boom, Trash Taste sweatpants.
- Sweatpants!
- Now these are the prototype version,
so the embroidery isn't on there,
but there will be a Trash
Taste logo embroidered on it.
I've got to say boys, this
is some high quality merch.
- Dude, everything is so comfortable.
- Speaking of the
embroidery, look at this,
look how cute this is.
- It's so cute.
You have the Apari little character,
sitting on the Trash
Taste and After Dark set.
- And you got embroidery
on the T-shirts as well.
So you don't have to worry about it fading
'cause it's embroidered in.
Look at that.
- It can never fade!
- It is obviously a little more pricey
than our previous merch,
but it is such high quality.
It's really good
- You are gonna get
the best high quality merch from us.
- Any of the people who have
bought Apari stuff before,
as it normally sells out
whenever we promote it,
you'll know the Apari
stuff is good quality.
And I promise it's worth the price tag.
- And guys, we heard you.
We heard you like the postcards.
So we decided to give everyone
a personalized postcard this time.
(Joey screaming)
- Signed by the boys of course.
- Hell yeah.
- But the first thousand
will get a special postcard.
We're not gonna spoil what's on it,
but they're gonna get a special one.
- The SSR of postcards.
- Ohh.
- And of course they're gonna be numbered.
We're still waiting for
number 69 and number 420
to make themselves known
for the Trash Taste merch.
- Where are you guys, come on out.
- So what are you waiting
for go and get your merch
by using the link down below and yeah.
Hope you get dripped out with the boys.
- But be quick,
because there's only
three weeks of pre-order.
- Oh shit Joey, I forgot to mention that.
There's only three
weeks left to grab this.
- These will not be round forever,
so click that link in the description,
grab them while you can.
- Orders ends at the end of the year.
So it's easy for you to
know when this deal ends.
- 2022 rolls over, you
will not see these merch
so grab them quick.
- Get you merch,
get your merch
- Links in the description
- Grab it now do it now.
- Get that Trash Taste drip.
- Get your Trash Taste merch do it.
- Drip out
- On with the episode.
- I have zero expectation man.
If I get ten Twitter followers after this,
I'm fucking happy.
(children cheering)
- Must be something wrong
with you that's the case.
- Yeah it's his fault.
- Yeah it's definitely his fault.
- It's like well fuck that guy.
(bright upbeat music)
- I'm dead on the inside.
Welcome to Trash Taste Podcast.
- Wow, that was an intro Joey.
- That was definitely an intro.
- You guys were like,
"Oh what happened to the Joey intros man.
I want them back."
So, I brought them back.
- Is that a Joey intro?
- That was a Joey intro.
- We've gone from like combini,
"I'm not gonna say the words"
to a "I'm dead inside."
How did we go from one
side to the other Joe?
It makes no sense.
- What a tragic evolution.
- Yeah that's what happens man.
When you do Trash Taste for that long,
that's what happens.
- We have devolved.
- We've devolved, yeah.
I'm Joey and as always,
I'm with the other two people
who are dead inside, Garnt and Connor.
- But you're making me dead inside.
- I know.
- Who's our guest Joey?
- I don't know, introduce yourself.
- Well, what's up guys?
It's your homie, Jan.
AKA 'SushiKebabGuy'
Nice to meet y'all today.
- How are you man?
- I'm good bro.
- You are so nervous, it's so funny.
- I'm shitting myself man,
(all laughing)
oh my God.
- So Jan is a friend of ours,
a mutual friend of ours.
And you are, or you were a host.
- Indeed.
- I mean, we met you
through mutual friends,
you know when you meet
someone in your life
and you just think like,
wow, you're one of the
most interesting people
I've ever met.
Because like, Jan's one
of those people who,
whenever you go to a party,
whenever you speak to him,
he'll have a new story every fucking time.
(all laughing)
I don't know how you do it,
'cause we've hung out so many times
and every time we hang out,
you come out with a new story
about something that's
happened in your life.
So like even on this podcast,
there's so many questions
I want to ask about
your life experience here in Japan.
Because, unlike any of
our previous guests,
Jan doesn't have an internet presence.
- True.
- Yeah.
- Yet.
So, it's understandable
that he's a bit nervous.
So go easy on him guys
- But it's also like,
how often do you just come across a dude
who used to be a host?
Because I feel that's just a part
of Japanese subculture life
that you just don't hear about.
- It seems very, very Japanese.
And from what I saw it
was extremely Japanese.
- I feel the only time you
would ever get to know a host
is if you yourself end up
going to a host club enough
that you get to know a host
and I mean the three of us don't.
- I mean, almost no foreigners
become hosts anyway,
even if your half like me.
No one really applies to become one.
- So you're half- Turkish, half-Japanese?
- Yeah, I'm half-Turkish, half-Japanese.
So, (speaking in foreign language)
if there are any Turkish
people watching, what's up.
(all laughing)
- That Turkish represent, let's go.
- You got it man.
- Is that a part of Turkish culture?
Because...
- Hell yeah, man.
- Anytime we go out and we'll have Jan,
he meets another Turkish person.
- For sure, man.
- It's like
the long-lost brothers.
And like, you get free shit
and you take care of them,
they take care of you.
And I'm just like, what is going on?
- It's like the world's strongest magnets.
- They're just like, from distance.
- I remember we were at
a restaurant one time
and they were like,
you got to leave in like one hour.
And then the manager of
the restaurant was Turkish
and he was also named Jan.
(all laughing)
It was like, the moment
that he found that out,
the guy was like,
"Oh no, no, you stay as long as you want.
You're having a nice time,
whatever you wanna do."
And it's like, what is this, bro?
What is this?
This is insane.
- They actually wanted to
move us if you remember.
- Yeah, they did.
Oh, yeah yeah.
- So I think we managed
to stay in our spot.
Like they moved the guests away.
(all laughing)
I shit you not.
People booked that place.
And we're like we're going over our time
and then they told the guests like,
oh, these guys, they're not gonna move.
Let's go there.
I mean the Japanese
people, they're like yeah.
- They go to that guest like,
"Are you a Jan?
I didn't think so.
- I think if you hang out with you,
one thing you notice is that,
you're not very Japanese in certain ways.
- I mean, I hope so.
- But that's almost,
being a host requires you
to be extremely extroverted.
And I think that applies to you.
I've never seen someone haggle in Japan,
but this man haggles in Japan.
(all laughing)
- I didn't even know you were
allowed to haggle in Japan
until I saw Jan do it.
- Well, hey, you got to try it, right.
And then see what happens.
- Just based on pre-assumptions
of how Japanese,
that kind of stuff in Japan works, right?
I was watching you haggle
for the first time,
I'm like, I was scared,
are you doing something illegal?
Because it just looked so wrong.
- I'm just like,
sometimes you go out with
Jan and I'm just like,
I didn't know you could do this.
Because it just wasn't
part of the rule sets
that I was taught in Japanese culture.
But I mean, I guess that's
how you found yourself
in a position, like becoming a host.
- We should go like the
backstory of how Jan,
I guess how you, first of all,
like ended up coming to Japan.
Were you born in Japan?
- No I was born in Turkey actually.
So I was born and raised in
Turkey until I was like 16.
Japanese school until seventh grade
and then international
school until 10th grade.
And then I moved to the
United Arab Emirates, Dubai.
So I was in Dubai for two years,
came back to Turkey
for Uni, for two years,
went to Czech Republic
and then on my final year I
went to (indistinct) so Tokyo.
I graduated here and then
decided to stay here.
So I was in Jochi.
- What is that?
- It's like a central Tokyo university.
- Jochi is nasty bro.
Like one of the four
hottest chicks in Tokyo.
That's what they say, Jochi University
- They call it the university
of the hottest chick?
- No, no, there's like tall hottest girls-
(group chattering)
- So we clearly know why he
decided to go to this uni.
- So you were born a host, I guess?
- Well, no, I'm a fucking introvert guys.
- Shut up.
(all laughing)
- That's the biggest lie of the century.
- This guys been on
YouTube for five minutes
and he's claiming to be an introvert.
- Like actual introverts
watching this show are like,
get the fuck out of here, man.
You are not one of us.
- The internet has ruined
the term introvert now,
'cause now everyone
claims to be an introvert.
Now we have a literal fucking host-
- You can't just say you're an introvert
to try and be humble.
This doesn't work that way.
- What are your justifications?
Tell us why-
- Why are you an introvert?
- All right. So,
for example, I love just being by myself
- Who doesn't?
- Okay.
See the thing is like,
I feel the need to hang out,
I understand that because if I don't,
I don't get to make new friends,
I don't get to do fun stuff.
But when I'm outside
hanging out with people,
I shit you not, 95% of
the time, I'm always like,
I'd rather be at home,
play League of Legends
or some shit.
Or like watch anime.
- That doesn't make you an introvert,
that just makes you unsociable.
- I don't even wanna play league.
(all laughing)
- Maybe he is introverted then.
- See, that's what I'm saying, bro.
Like I shit you not.
I do spend a lot of time
outside socializing with people,
'cause I also do enjoy that.
- No, no, no,
but like I think you understand,
an introverted person is
incapable of being social.
- No, no, no.
- Because either they don't
have the confidence to be social
or because they don't know how to.
That's how I see an introvert.
- I think that's like,
obviously if you're introverted,
an introvert doesn't mean like
you're scared of social interaction,
that might be some introverts
but that's not every introvert.
It's like the length of a scale.
There's a severity.
- But like, I'd say I'm an introvert
and the best way I can
describe it is that,
I can be a social person,
I have this battery,
it's my social battery.
And if I don't interact
with people for a long time,
that battery, like it
fills up to the point where
it starts like overflowing to be like,
okay, I just wanna go
out and talk to people.
But when I go out and
socialize that battery depletes
and depletes more depletes more.
And sometimes it just gets
completely fucking empty.
Like you boys have hung
out with me sometimes
where I'm just like,
I'm just not gonna say a word,
this time I'm hanging out.
I'm just like, you guys can just talk
and I'm just gonna sit here.
- Does that have to do with
being introverted though?
Because I feel even
extroverts are like that.
- If you're tired.
- What I've heard about extroverts is that
they actually get energy
from social interaction.
So they start off the
day with an empty battery
and then they go out and socialize
and that's how they energize themselves.
- That's how I feel okay
- If I'm alone for too long,
I start to get like sad and shit.
- Do you now?
(all laughing)
- Well, guys, I invited this guy,
well, what I invited
myself over to his house
(all laughing)
- If there's one thing you
need to know about Jan,
you don't invite Jan, Jan invites himself.
- I'm gonna get called out now.
- To watch the fucking finals.
Well, not the finals,
but T1 versus Dom One.
- It was the League of Legends semi final
- So, 'cause I heard this guy mention
that he feels lonely.
People don't hit him up.
- No, no, no, no.
That's misconstrued.
- He has no friends.
- I got you, man.
Let's watch some league, let's
have a nice drink together,
let's hang out.
And he's like, ah,
excuses, excuses, excuses.
- That's not what happened.
- Shut the fuck up.
- I agreed to go to
something and I forgot.
And then I went to the thing
and it wasn't that good.
I rather wish I watched
the League of Legends
- That's what you were telling me,
and I was like, well, yeah.
- So like going back to the host thing
and your backstory for a second,
so you are half Japanese, half Turkish.
So your mom taught you Japanese?
- My dad is Japanese actually.
And my mom's Turkish.
(Connor laughing)
- I love my mom.
- He loves his mom, man.
- If I think about her, I
gotta say something nice.
- I'm sure she's a lovely lady.
- That's cute.
- So like how did you get fluent?
Because you're pretty damn fluent.
As someone who also is half,
not even half actually.
I don't know why I'm half.
- I was about to go like,
what are you half with?
- My parents are fully Thai,
but I grew up in a different country.
So it's half in a sense.
But like I'm full-blooded Thai,
but still I grew up in another culture
and I wouldn't say I'm
like fully fluent in Thai.
So if you're fluent in,
I say like your mother tongue
language, like Joey is,
you've really had to go out and study it.
So how did you get fluent in it?
- Well, I lived in Turkey,
so I didn't really have to study it,
'cause I'm like surrounded by it.
But Japanese, so starting
from first grade,
I was enrolled in a Japanese
school until seventh grade.
And my dad never spoke to
me in any other language.
He was so persistent to just
speak to me in Japanese.
- That's exactly how my mom did.
- Bro, see, great parenting.
- Look at us now.
- Exactly.
- Now we're fun.
- Look at us.
- Built different.
I agree though, that
is the hundred percent
the way to do it.
Because any other method,
if you slip up with another language,
then it just lets the kid know,
oh, I can get away with just
speaking another language.
- Does that get you fluent though?
'Cause I swear, that takes
you up to a certain level,
but it doesn't get your like-
- You obviously have to study it as well,
which I did a lot of and
I'm sure you did as well.
So to go over the story,
there were like chores that
I can earn money out of
by filling out (speaks
in foreign language).
So the (indistinct)
studying fucking textbooks.
If I like got one correct,
I would get like 0.5 Turkish liras,
which is like 10 yen or some shit.
- You got money for studying?
(all laughing)
I just got my meal for the day.
That wasn't a reward in my house,
that was like an obligation.
- He was in a pay to win house.
(group chattering)
- He came out of the womb haggling.
(all laughing)
- Mother trade-off, trade-off oh, mother,
I complete kanji test, you give me money.
(all laughing)
- But yeah, I think that was
one of the biggest incentives
for me to actually go learn.
- Money is a big incentive
for a lot of things,
- Absolutely, yeah.
- And because at that
age as well, like even,
like 10 cents is like, whoa,
- Yeah, for sure.
You're trying to get your like
ice cream money for the day.
That's why you're focused.
- How did you decide on a pricing system
where you just like (indistinct)
- I actually had to haggle with my dad
(all laughing)
So obviously,
So actually, now that
you guys talk about it,
I actually wanna go on a huge tangent.
- This is Trash Taste.
- Fitting in all right.
- Whenever I went to your house,
so that I can get with
all of us and whatnot,
there would always be a period
where it's only you and me
on your balcony and we're
like reflecting on our lives.
- It's like the 5:00 AM talk.
- I'm always gone by like 3:00 AM.
- You're always just like peace out.
Then Garnt is always like,
"bro, why are you so fucked up?"
(all laughing)
Tell me about it.
(group chattering)
You're asking that to me,
really helped me go over stuff with you
because I mean,
it's a new perspective that
you're adding here, right?
- Thank you, man.
Like how I know when I'm going to bed,
when I hang out with Jan
is when I see the sun.
That's like,
well it's 'cause the sun's
kind of coming up, Jan,
I should probably get to bed right now.
- I just love how you just,
you found out how fucked up your life was
because Garnt was like,
why are you so fucked up, bro?
- In detailed fashion,
he went over certain aspects
of what we talked about.
You know, how I ended
up doing certain things,
some decision making.
And really put your own
fault into your answers
and your evaluation that
made me kind of understand.
- Garnt's a good father figure.
- He's a good father figure, for sure.
- A father figure/therapist, I would say.
- I'm just a big brother, come on.
- I'm not a dad yet, guys.
I'm not a dad yet.
- He's the Onii Chan of
Trash Taste, that's for sure.
- Garnt is the wisest person I know.
- I'd say so.
- I think it's the Zen like
monk state that he has.
Garnt just sees things differently.
I don't know, it hits different.
- He sees things through his third eye.
- He does, he does.
- Except for food.
- Except for that.
- He sees things through his third eye,
but his other two eyes he doesn't see shit
- Garnt'll be right, but
I'll just disagree with him.
- One random question,
do people still pick on you
for the way you drink stuff?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
Here's the thing, here's the thing.
In my entire life,
no one has ever picked on me
for the way I drink stuff.
And now, only as Trash Taste has started
has people, have I
noticed how I drink things
and I've never noticed that
before I started Trash Taste.
- Being on camera sucks, huh?
- Thank you.
- You are kind of forced
to strive for perfection
on this show.
Like any one slip up and our
audience is like, gotcha!
(group chatter)
- There you go.
(all laughing)
- So Jan, if you got like fluent in Kanji
like I assimilated Joey?
- Can't write for shit though.
- You can't write?
- But you can read Kanji,
right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's the usual-
- I mean, when I talk to Jan,
it's like I'm talking to a native.
I can tell not only you
are actually flowing,
but you also like,
'cause there are people
who just know the vocab,
but don't actually understand the culture
behind the language.
When I speak to Jan,
it's like he clearly
also gets the culture.
- I think that's because
we both follow anime manga,
We're deep into that shit.
- It also helps again that your dad,
did that whole early Japanese technique,
which I honestly would
recommend to any parent.
- There's two examples that's
been proven to work, right?
- It's a must man.
It's a must, honestly.
- I think so too.
- So when did you move
to Japan originally?
Like come live here.
- So I visit every year
to see my grandparents
and hanging out here
and I think that's one
of the reasons also why,
that there's no cultural gap,
in my vocabulary, for example.
But I moved here permanently
about three years ago.
So right after graduating from Jochi,
to actually start working here.
- And became a host.
- No, so that's never been
my like main profession.
- So is there a side hustle?
- Yeah, basically.
- How long have you
been doing it for, man?
(all laughing)
- Of course I started after 18.
- Yeah, of course.
- Its not like is started
anytime before that,
so it's been how long?
Seven years since I started, I guess.
'Cause I'm 25 now.
- Is that a long time for a host?
Like what's like the average
that a host would be a host for like?
- It really depends on the club,
but I would say like the general
life span of a single host
is pretty short.
- It seems like it.
- Pretty short.
- How long do you think you can last this?
- Well the thing is like
in my case, for example,
do you know,
I wasn't like a full time, right?
Like for example, until
I moved here permanently,
it was always like a
summer, one month thing.
So for like the audience
or like the customers,
it was like, oh my God,
I can only see this dude one
month out of the whole year.
- That's crazy 'cause for me it's like,
during my breaks.
I would just like go and play
X-Box, like the whole time.
I didn't even have the
capacity to even find...
- Jan was all that grind.
- How did you even like,
so you became a host
you said like what, for
one month, for summer?
- How did that start?
(group chattering)
- I'm so curious.
- Okay, so to go over
since, even before I was 18,
I would always go to Kabukicho.
- The host central.
- The red light district.
Probably the closest thing
to a red light district.
- That's where all the (indistinct)
fun, cool shit happens.
- And sketchy stuff.
- But you know,
I would hear stories from my dad
how old this street was.
'Cause my dad used to work there too
at a bar called Saboten.
My dad is like a huge ass motherfucker.
So he was like a bouncer
for one of the bars
back in the day.
So he would tell me how
he used to play card
with people who are missing
a portion of their finger,
and stuff like that.
So I was really curious to see like,
what is this place like now?
So I would go there with my-
- Before you're 18?
- Just to look around.
So I would go there
and the people there just
treated me like I'm an adult.
- It do be like that when
you like half Turkish.
- [Jan] We have a fucking beard like this.
- If you have a beard you're
40 years old in Japan.
- I never had an issue with like buying
or doing anything here.
So at summer I would go
there just to experience
what it's like, you know, see places.
It's not like I did anything,
was just gonna looking.
And then, once I turned 18,
I decided, well, when I'm going to Japan,
I should probably make some money.
Meaning I should do some baito.
'Cause my dad was like,
"well, now that you're 18,
I ain't gonna give you any money, bro."
Just do something, you know?
So I was like, all right,
am I gonna work at a
fucking pizzeria or hostel?
And then I decide to choose the pizzeria.
- Why was that your two options?
- Surely there's more choices.
(all laughing)
- Father I will work for Domino's
or this sketchiest bar in Tokyo,
which one should I choose?
(all laughing)
- When you put it like
that, its such fucking-
- It's not my first two choices.
- So to go over why that.
- Could've just worked at McDonald's.
(group chatter)
- The way it transpired
is that when I turned 18
near my parents' house,
there was a pizzeria called,
I'm not gonna name it
because it's my surname.
- What's a pizzeria?
- It's a pizza shop.
- Okay, I understood that
was it just wanna make sure.
- It's a pizza shop.
- So the shop's name was
literally my surname.
So I went there, chat with the guy.
He's like, yo we have the same surname.
And he looks like exactly like me, bro.
This guy, Japanese has a beard,
huge nose and everything.
- Was he Turkish?
- No, he's not.
But we became really good friends.
And he will say, why don't you work here?
I heard you're here for the summer.
I'll give you a good cash.
900 yen an hour.
- Baller.
It's like 10 bucks an hour.
- But he was like, free food all day, bro.
I'm like, shit, let's go.
So I started working
there for a few months.
When I was 18,
I stayed in Japan for much
longer than one month actually,
probably like four months.
The first two months I
was there, I worked there.
And then I started taking the night shifts
because my (indistinct)
wanted me to make drinks
and serve it to the
customers at the counter.
- It was like a pizza
place that sold alcohol?
- Exactly.
- Right.
- And so the main customers
that come in the evening
were MILFs, let's say.
(all laughing)
(group chatter)
- I'm happy with that.
- So he was like, yo Jan...
So he's like an ex sports teacher.
He still has good ties with the school
and all of his like ex students,
he's still in contact with,
- Are now all adults.
- Yeah.
And most of the females are like married.
they have kids, they're like 25.
And when you're 25
and you're married to a
30 year old Japanese guy
and he's away a lot
and maybe he has a kind
of erectile dysfunction.
She kind of wants to go
talk to other people.
- Okay, I was gonna say that,
we fucking at the pizzeria?
(all laughing)
We fucking a chunk of cheese?
- I'm just giving you some context.
- Well, what you're
describing literally sounds
like the start of a porn.
(all laughing)
- I know, I know, I know.
Guys, that's gonna happen a
lot throughout this episode.
- I mean, one thing that we
should probably mention is that
cheating culture in Japan
is pretty prevalent.
- It's very normal, unfortunately.
- Nuts, bro.
It's crazy.
So I started working at this pizza place.
Taking the night shifts,
making drinks for these ladies,
chatting with them.
And I realized they're coming back
specifically to chat with me.
That's what the boss is telling me.
They're like, yo,
these ladies, they wanna
hang out with you after.
- It's a dangerous feeding an 18 year old.
- And then I realized
that they're allowed to buy drinks for me
while I'm making drinks for them.
So I'm like-
- The fuck out of pizza place is this?
(group chattering)
- Where did we get the drinks from?
I had the image of like
the Domino's counter,
you're just taking orders.
- I don't think this is a pizza place,
I think this is a bar that serves pizza.
- It's like a really high end pizza place.
That has a really sexy counter
with a lot of high-end
alcohol kind of lined up.
And then there's a nice stool
that people can sit on and then drink
one-to-one with the bartender.
- So a bar?
- Well, with pizza attached to it.
- So it's a bar that serves pizza,
it's not a pizza place.
- All right, all right.
Is that what you're stuck on, really?
- So when the wife goes there,
she can be like, no, no,
I'm not going to a bar,
I'm going to get a pizza.
(group chattering)
- Fantastic excuse for your husband.
- You don't have to feed the
pizza boy, he's a pizza boy.
(all laughing)
- So after like a month
or so working there,
in the night shift, I realized that,
I maybe good at this.
So my boss was like,
and he's such a nice guy, bro.
- Are you still in contact with him?
- Yeah, of course, of course.
'Cause I go hang out with him,
still ready to sales and shit.
So he told me,
'cause I was talking to
him about becoming a host,
like initially.
But I told him,
I don't wanna let my parents
down and shit like that.
- So why did you wanna
be a host initially?
- Easy money man.
- Easy money?
- Bro, guys, like, think about it.
There's a job where you
literally get paid money
to drink with girls and
just chat with them.
- And when I did my video,
the money I saw that they
were getting paid was insane.
- It's nuts.
- It was like,
some of them could make
like $50,000 a night.
- Easy, if it's your birthday,
- Why were you (indistinct)
- They fucking laughed at me.
When they were like, how much do you make?
And I told them how much
I made like a year before.
And they were like,
"That's how much you made?"
And they all started fucking laughing.
(all laughing)
I was like, what the fuck?
- They're like, look at this peasant.
- Some of them don't pay tax.
(group chattering)
Exactly, just write off whatever the fuck.
It's crazy bro.
- So, okay.
So what was the process of like
getting into your first hosting job then?
- So after the pizza stuff
I decided to apply, right?
- Apply, like do you just talk to someone
or do you have like a job offer?
- So you go on the
internet guys, holy shit.
So you're just type in (indistinct)
and then you just find it.
So you just find the nearest ones.
So I went to one in Ikebukuro
'cause that was like
five minutes train away
from where I was living at the time.
(all laughing)
- Not sure if that was a...
- That was a tension sip.
- This is like his host side coming out.
- He's drinking a gin
and tonic by the way.
- It's like 2:00 in the afternoon.
- We wanna drink, but we can't.
We have our health check tomorrow.
- Can we go over just real quick,
I have to get it out of my chest.
So people listen to me.
We've been discussing
about this podcast day
for like a year, since we met.
- We were trying to get
Jan for a while now.
- And then I was always like,
we're gonna get fucking
smashed when I show up.
Are you guys fucking ready?
And last week, I had to cancel
because some shit happened.
And then, I said, how about
next week, what is it?
Let's do it.
And I show up today with this bottle
and their first thing they say,
they're like, oh, I
can't drink today though.
(all laughing)
- I'm sorry.
- To be fair, Jan,
we have been asking you for a whole year,
52 weeks, which is not
this week to say yes.
- So that's a valid enough excuse
to not let me know that
you can't drink this week.
- Well, we didn't think about it.
- We didn't think about it.
I actually completely forgot
I had a health checkup until this morning.
I was like, oh yeah, that's tomorrow.
- I have no excuse.
- We'll drink when the cameras are off,
when it's not today,
like we always do, Jan.
- In fact, the day that this
episode goes up, we'll drink,
how's that?
- Fuck yeah, let's do it.
- So save it until then.
- So I'll camper you
with some cucumber water.
- You leaving me hanging, bro.
- I thought the campier was gone,
I thought it was like a group campier.
- No, it doesn't work that way, bro.
- I wanted to go around
campier everyone individually,
I'm like, cheers, cheers.
- I mean Jan does it, right?
- He's a host though.
- This episode is
sponsored by Express VPN.
- Using the internet
without using Express VPN
is like leaving your keys in the car
while you run to the
gas station for a snack.
Most of the time, you're probably fine.
But what if you come back to see someone
driving off with your car.
Every time you connect to
a non-encrypted network,
cafes, hotels, airports,
any hacker on the same
network can gain access
to your personal data, passwords,
financial details, et cetera.
- And it really doesn't take
much technical knowledge
to hack someone, just some
cheap hardware's needed.
Even Joey could do it
without his graphics cards.
- Your data is valuable
and hackers can make
up to $1,000 per person
selling personal
information on the dark web.
- But guys, why use Express VPN?
Well, let me tell you,
it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device
and the internet.
Hackers can't steal your
sensitive data at all.
- It would take Joey over a billion years
to try and hack into your computer
and a billion more if you had Express VPN.
- Plus it works on all your devices,
phones, laptops, tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go.
- And everyone who watches Trash Taste
know that I use Express VPN.
It's easy, it's very easy to use.
It's just simple, you can't fuck it up,
you can change the
country, it's super easy.
I just use it 'cause it's painless.
- Even I can use it.
- So secure your data today by visiting
expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
That's E X P R E S S vpn.com/TrashTaste.
And you can get an
extra three free months.
- That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
Links in the description below.
- All right, so yeah.
Tell us how you got into this.
- So you looked up host club, Tokyo,
and then you apply for a one Ikebukuro.
And then you just walked in?
- Yeah, basically.
- Is it that easy?
- Well, they have an interview.
And they actually pay you
to go to the interview.
- Why?
- Can you believe that?
- Is that new or has it
always been like that?
- This is where the
difference in clubs come in.
So for example, if you go
to a very well-known club
in Kabukicho, like Palacina
if you know, that's
like one of the fucking,
most prestigious clubs.
- I know the name.
- So they're not gonna
pay you to go there.
You're gonna go there, you're
gonna do the interview,
and they're gonna tell you
to fuck off, 90% of the time.
But smaller clubs in butt-fuck nowhere
like Ikebukuro, kind of,
they are lacking staff.
So they need more hosts
to actually fill the place.
So they actually pay people
to take the interviews,
'cause they can afford it.
- Wait, so they pay you
even if you don't get in?
- Yeah, exactly.
They pay for your time, bro.
So actually the first-
- Sorry, is the host industry that big,
that we have like a
shortage of like employees
in the host industry?
- I mean, there is a
shit load of host clubs
just in Tokyo.
So I mean, I guess the demand is there.
I guess it's not really like apparent.
Maybe you could just
look at it from a surface
of like just how much in demand it is.
- I think back in the day,
at least for girls bars I've read that,
they would literally
just like hire tourists.
They're not allowed to, obviously
but they would hire foreign
girls for girls bars
on tourist visas.
- [Jan] That would work.
Girls would just walk into bars,
and go like, I wanna work here.
- I met a girl like that
the other day, actually.
- Of course you did.
- Near a girl's bar next to my house
that I always go to just to
check out who's new and stuff,
there was this Russian girl,
who was here for like exchange.
She's only here for like four months.
(group chattering)
- It's nothing illegal,
but she's still there.
- I'm sure that's not the
dodgiest thing you've seen,
but we'll get into.
We'll get into some of
the other stories later.
- So you join this,
you get paid for the
interview, you're successful.
- So I hop to places,
and then at that time I was thinking like,
how about, I hope like 50
places and not join any of them?
- No, 'cause when you said
that they would pay you
and not even join, I'm just
like, oh, that's an idea.
What if I just applied
to jobs and not join.
- How does this interview process go then?
Do they just make you drink?
- So you go, you fill
in like a basic sheet.
That's kind of the employment thing,
your name, your address and whatnot.
And then they ask you questions
just to chat with you.
Have you ever done this before?
I'm I good at socializing?
Can you handle drinks?
How late can you work for?
- So you're not an introvert..
- I just watch League of Legends and...
(all laughing)
(group chattering)
- But yeah.
I was gonna originally
do like a hopping thing,
just to collect.
And they pay a lot.
They pay like 4,000,
some of them pay 6,000,
just to go to an interview
which finishes in like an hour, bro.
I know, right, crazy.
- So how many hours was
that in the pizzeria?
- It's like five, six
hours in the pizzeria.
- Six hours, like a single interview.
- That place was not about money.
It's about like the friends
we made along the way.
(all laughing)
- How much longer do we have
to have him on the show?
- Whoa, come on, man.
I haven't even started
talking about the good shit.
Bro, we need this thing to go
down until like the midpoint.
- This is 47%, by the way.
- [Garnt] Which is one shot of vodka.
- How sad is this though, just
getting smashed by myself.
(all laughing)
- Anyway, yeah.
So, you decided to join the Ikebukuro one?
- Oh, yeah.
So after two interviews,
I decided, you know what,
I kind of liked this place.
So it was a really interesting one
because until that point
they never really made me
sit with an actual customer.
But for the Ikebukuro
place that I went to,
it was called Acid.
That place literally made
me sit down with a customer
and just drink with
them, like straight up.
- So it wasn't even like,
it was like trial by fire?
It was just an actual
customer that was there?
- Yeah, exactly.
But it was like one of
the closed, you know,
customers of one of the members there.
The shachou asked him like,
is it okay if we have
like this random ass guy,
just chat with her for a bit,
just to see if he is capable
and she said, fuck yeah.
So I sat down, drank
Yeager bombs with her.
- (scoffs) Was that her choice?
- My choice bro.
- Oh my God.
- Of course you're 18 at the
time, that makes so much sense.
- Red Bull, Red bull, Red
bull, put it in my veins?
- So we drank jager bombs and Cocalero.
You know Cocalero?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Shit's crazy.
- The green one, right?
It's got like some substance
in it, that's like-
- It's like green, I think
is actually in the alcohol.
- Yeah, actually, something like that.
- It's awful for your heart.
- I'm not surprised bro.
- I think I served it in
the gay bar the other day.
- It's like a green one, yeah
- Red bull bottom
- Red bull with Cocalero, Jesus Christ!
- It's Red bull in the bottom,
and then it's the 40% spirit on top
and like they're not supposed to mix.
So the idea is that it's this presentation
that's fancy and stuff.
- I think you could pull
someone out of a coma with that.
- Yeah, genuinely.
Dude, we should just
christen people with that.
The fucking (indistinct)
(group chattering)
- Sorry go ahead.
- So you sat down with this
lady, just to try it out?
- Yeah, just start drinking with her.
- So that was your first time?
- Yeah, first time ever.
- Did you kill it?
Did it go well?
Was it awkward?
- No, not at all, man.
- What did you talk about?
- Like, why did you come here?
Well, I'm trying it out.
I'm a student, blah, blah, blah.
- Oh shoot, it looks like
she was interviewing you.
- Kind of.
- That was the real interview.
This is like some undercover (indistinct)
I'm actually the owner of this place.
- The thing is, I'll get
into this a bit more later,
but like, in like the
traditional way of doing hosting,
you're supposed to have the
other person talk the most
and that's with any sales tactic, right?
If you come out of an
interview in general,
talking more than the other person,
that means you have to do the selling.
If you make the other person talk more,
that means, they're trying to
do something to impress you
or they're just having a good time
that they just wanna talk more.
But in this case she was just
asking me questions like,
where are you from?
Why do you have fucking beard?
How are you 18?
Oh, you look 35 and stuff like that.
And like the more I asked her stuff,
intrigued her more to ask more questions.
So, at the end she said, I
wanna see this guy again.
Fucking hire him.
And the guy was like,
let's go, start tomorrow.
- You make it sound so simple.
Just ask questions, bro.
- I mean you guys probably not,
but you could become a host tomorrow, bro.
- Why me?
- 'Cause you speak Japanese.
(all laughing)
- It doesn't mean I'm good at socializing.
- You're fun.
- Not that I have any plans to be a host.
That's all right guys, I'm not going to.
- Well, we have a plan, don't you think?
- Yeah, I wanna do like
a version two of it.
- What do you mean?
- The host club video
- Oh, the host club video.
- You should go with Jan,
and like show you around.
- Well I wanna take you
to my homie's place,
show you around.
- When Jan says homie's
place, this is like,
I just think of like the most sketch shit.
I don't know why.
- I have like my preconceptions
of host clubs and whatnot,
just from filming my video
where I went to host club
and I got to see everything there.
And obviously we cut a lot of
stuff that I couldn't share.
But one misconception I had
about host clubs is that
I thought you had to be like,
like literally looking like a
rockstar, like sexy as fuck.
It's like you literally just
have to have like a gimmick,
almost.
And this guy's gimmick was
that he was an asshole.
That was like his character, right Maley?
So I think I was...
Who's a bit larger.
- [Woman] I think he calls himself a piggy
- Oh he calls himself a pig?
And also I am very
grateful they let me film.
I mean, they really did
like give me like all access
and like-
- It's pretty tough to get permission.
- They're really nice about it.
- Did you have to like
hook them up and stuff?
- No.
- No?
- I didn't do anything, did we?
We literally shouted out
his YouTube, I think.
That was it.
It was one of the situations where
I didn't really know what was going on.
I don't think any of us really
knew what was happening.
We just kind of got dragged
in and we were doing it
and I didn't know if I
was gonna pay for stuff.
But like, he was, from
what I was gathering,
like he was being rude.
Like it was partially a character,
but I think that was partially some of it
that might've been how
he actually behaves.
- It has to have stemmed from somewhere.
- He was trying to be funny as well.
Like he was trying to
crack jokes at my expense,
which I didn't mind.
I can take that.
- Yeah, just fucking crazy and haha.
- Sometimes when you bring
cameras into a place like that,
sometimes people feel like they wanna,
wanna-
- Show off.
- Do I seem like that to you right now?
- No, no.
I know you, fuck off!
- You're more of an asshole off camera.
(all laughing)
- That is not the case,
trust me that is not the case.
- But yeah, it was interesting.
What shocked me the most was
how transparent it all was.
Like the hosts were like very transparent
with about that life.
They were like, we don't care,
but they do this whole
act that they do care,
but it's so obviously they don't
and they almost tell them that
they don't care in many ways.
It's really-
- Hard to the customers.
- Yeah, it's really strange.
- That's where we go into
the whole psychology of it.
And then the tactics they employ
to actually garner these...
- It's something I don't
think I can quite...
If you're not from Japan,
it would take years for you
to wrap your head around
because you feel like
you need to understand
what led up to this as a culture.
(group chattering)
- So like as a host, what is
the big appeal of host clubs?
From the other side.
- Yeah, why does so many girls in Japan
love going to host clubs
and not just going,
but like spending
gargantuan amounts of money
on these hosts?
- Very good question.
So this has kind of a lot of sides to it,
but the main answer, I would say is
just the social structure of Japan itself.
As he also mentioned,
Japan is not really like
social friendly place,
especially when you look
at the type of people
that actually go to the host clubs.
So again, a huge tangent,
but the reason why I
wanted to go to host club
or one of the reasons
is to see what kind of
people actually work there
and what kind of people actually go there.
'Cause it makes no sense,
like why would I spend
money to chat with guys?
And I can just go to you bar
and pay to drink with a guy,
that's a girl.
So once I entered,
that was like the main
thing that I looked into.
What kind of people go there?
Why do they go there?
And what kind of people
actually work there?
So what I figured out is,
most of the customers that we would get,
and I'm sure it's the
same across the board.
They're also people who
work in the nightlife.
- Yeah, I noticed that.
- Easy, I would say more than
80% of the people that we got,
there were always-
- Like, Kyabakura, (indistinct)
- Kyabakura, (indistinct) whatever,
some kind of a nightlife where
your pride, your dignity,
it's fucking stepped on
all day long and it's,
you're out of your job.
The one thing you want is being pampered.
One thing you want is feeling
like you're being respected.
Even if it's artificial
as fuck, and you know it,
you wanna feel this guy
giving you this other
sense of service and then,
do anything for you kind of thing.
- Quite a depressing
aspect of Japanese culture.
- If you put it in that perspective, yeah,
but it's also its own
culture within itself
where once you go a lot to
a host club, for example,
you get to meet, the shachou,
like owners, basically,
of these host clubs.
And they're not like random-ass people.
They're usually the very
wealthy Japanese businessman.
And if you're in the nightlife,
then you get to hang out with the shachou,
he might elevate you
in some way or another.
Maybe he might put you in a different,
like a Kyabakura or something.
So there's actually different reasons
as to why you would go to the host club.
Depends on the person.
- So how often would you get,
like a newbie come to the host club?
Like, someone who was like-
- First time ever?
- Yeah, someone who's like
say not part of like the industry
or that kind of environment,
someone just like-
- Someone who's just,
curious to be like, oh, I
wanna see what a host is like.
- Actually when you start
off, that's your main goal.
You go outside the club,
you go nampa on the
street with random girls.
- What's nampa?
- Nampa's like hitting on them.
- Yeah, just hit on them.
(Garnt laughing)
- Bro, you're like a 2010 YouTuber.
(all laughing)
(group chatter)
Well you wanna make out?
- Camera's right there, just kidding.
- So, the thing was,
you just go up to them and be like,
hey, I work right there.
I would love to drink with you.
It's 1,600 yen per hour, whole day.
- What's the success rate of this?
- Like one in a hundred will be generous.
- Oh, they'll do it just
because they feel sorry for you?
- Ah, ah.
Bro, it's Japan, bro.
People value their time and money.
- And privacy.
- Exactly, exactly.
No one appreciates some
random dude getting this close
and being like (mumbles)
No one's gonna be like,
yeah, let's do it.
- 'Cause I see it all the time
when you go to like
Shinjuku of like these dudes
who clearly work at host clubs,
going up to these girls
and these girls just don't even give them,
like any attention at all.
- They're used to it, bro.
Japanese girls that go to these places,
they know that some catchy
guy is gonna come to you,
just walk straight ahead.
- It's kind of the same
with like, maid cafes,
but just like up the opposite way around.
So like you go to Akihabara or Kabukicho
and like see a lot of maids on the streets
trying to get people to come
in there maid cafes as well.
- And you're just like,
don't even give them periphery at all.
- Just like don't make eye
contact, don't make eye contact.
- The moment they realize in
the periphery they are there,
they'll just come up to you
and like give you a pamphlet.
Sucks.
- So like, so was that what you had to do
when you joined the host club?
Was that like your first jobs?
- Yeah, initially that was
my first ever proper job.
after the pizza bar.
So for the first, couple of months,
not even, like the first year,
'cause I wasn't living in Japan.
So for the first time I was
there in the second year
that I was there, you go in at 5:00 PM,
clean the fucking place
with your other homies
that are not selling.
So you just make everything
pristine as fuck.
And then your sampier
would come in and be like,
what's the fucking dirt there, bro?
Hey!
You know that thing.
- Kinda love that about you.
- It's fun because I still
make bouncer out of it.
Like no one would go up
to sampier and be like,
how about you do it
bitch, but I would do it.
Like I'll just get pissed off and be like,
number one, you think
you're the hot shit bitch,
come you clean it, I'm
not doing it, fuck you.
And he'll be like, yo, I like you.
(all laughing)
(group chattering)
- The sampier are all (indistinct)
- Like that's the whole industry, man.
(group chattering)
Absolutely.
And it's the same with the way
you approach the customers,
because the number one rule
they tell you when you join is,
do not ask them personal questions.
Don't ask them what they do,
their real name, their address,
how they make their living.
- It's so hard, 'cause I remember
when I did it, I was like,
fuck, when you meet someone
all you do is just ask them,
hey, what do you for a living?
I was like (groans) I
don't know what to ask
- And combined with
the fact that I'm also,
used to that,
but also my main purpose
was to do a survey as to,
why the fuck do people come
to these places anyway?
So, it was like crack, okay.
First girl I ever go into,
why are you here?
- Why are you here?
- Yeah, why are you here?
And my sampier are just
like, what the fuck?
- Did the girls like that?
- Well, that's what worked in my favor
because I was acting like this-
- That was your gimmick?
- Exactly.
- The girls were like, no
one's ever asked me that.
- This is a fucking anime blog, bro.
(group chattering)
- I love how your gimmick is,
you're the guy that gives the survey.
(all laughing)
Bring the survey guy!
- He is a YouTuber.
The social experiment guy.
- What's up guys, I'm here in Kabukicho.
- Well, the main purpose
also was to get information.
But again, I was playing this character
where I'm that guy,
who has no idea what the fuck he's doing,
but it's that friendly neighborhood
guy Jan doing his best.
That character.
- Gathering information.
- So was that a character you made up
or was that something you would just like,
okay, I know this is the
character I'm gonna play,
and I'm gonna play it out?
- Well, quite naturally really,
'cause I never gave a shit
what they told me to do
'cause I was like,
"Bro if you fire me today,
I'll go to the next place."
They pay me money to go to the interviews,
I don't give a care.
I never give a fuck.
- You figured out the system, man.
- Well, it's just all
about not giving a fuck.
- Hosts are gonna hate this one trick.
(all laughing)
- Click to find out.
- So, employing this tactic
of just asking these
girls, what do you do?
My main structure of conversation
was literally just being a
life coach to these girls, but-
- Bitcoin, NFT, buy, buy, invest invest!
(all laughing)
- Just to go over like
the general structure.
So I think last time I went over,
how I got chosen and shit,
so, you clean the stuff, you
start sitting down with girls
and then when there's a
new girl that comes in,
who has never been to that club before,
what you do is each guy
gets to sit down with her
for five minutes, just five minutes.
- I did that on my video.
- You give your card, you
compliment them, you talk to them.
And then after five
minutes they switch around.
- I love that host clubs
have business cards.
- Hosts have business cards.
- I should have brought mine today, bro
it's really sick.
- It's like some stock trading style.
Bring it out.
- Is it just like that
scene from American Psycho?.
Let me see your business card.
(group chattering)
( all laughing)
- Patrick Bateman moment, huh?
- It really was.
- So you got five minutes
to prove yourself.
- Exactly.
So you do that, you rotate
and after the first 45 or 50 minutes,
- They choose someone, right?
- Yeah.
- How do you stand out in five minutes?
- Well, see that's the thing, bro.
Most people just go like,
oh your eyes are beautiful.
I love your nails.
Stuff like that.
- Jan comes in, why are you here?
(group chattering)
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- That's what I do.
I'm like, wait, why are you here?
Why don't you go somewhere else
and hang out with your friends?
And she's like, what do you mean?
And I'm like, well,
- Oh my God, I love him.
- Well you are spending
money to drink with me
that means there's a
reason why you're here.
Why are you here?
And then I make them explain,
like justify their reason for being there.
So like, I clearly don't get
along with closed minded people
or people who are not willing to chat.
Bro, you would get ladies
that would just come in
and open their phones
and just scroll through.
And I see that for like
a minute and I'm like,
yeah, no, (indistinct)
boss, fucking change.
I'm not gonna sit with her.
- I mean to be fair,
that is a waste of money.
- But it's a waste of my time.
- It's a waste of the host's time.
- A lot of the host clubs,
they offer unlimited drinks.
- Exactly.
- For the first 60
minutes you're in there.
And it's normally considerably cheaper.
- [Jan] It's fucking cheap.
- It's like 1,000 yen
for like, all you can drink.
- So I guess girls just
come in to just drink.
- Yeah, because the next
drink, if you buy one beer,
its like 30 bucks.
- Everything is like ten
times the market price.
- It's like that with a lot of
like even girls bars as well.
That's how they get you in.
They get you in for the all you can drink,
and then they sell you
on other stuff, right?
- [Jan] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Luckily I think guys are a
little bit easier to convince,
to stay in the bar.
- Than the fucking girls, right?
- Yeah, I think so.
I think they are like,
oh, hot girl, I will stay.
- One thing I've always
been curious about is like,
how cutthroat is it?
How cutthroat is this industry?
- Honestly, again,
this comes down to what
kind of club you work at.
The place I was at,
it's like fucking teddy bears and sugar.
- And you're coming on Trash Taste,
and you're cleaning our set for us.
- I feel bad.
- Done a lot of the host clubs.
I don't know if yours did this,
but they rank all the staff, right?
- Oh yeah.
- This is some anime shit.
- Well, they have to,
'cause at the entrance...
So at my peak,
I was number 3 out of 20
people that were working there.
- Nice.
- Fuck, yeah.
- People's got power rankings here.
But can you beat Goku?
- Drip Goku was always at the top.
I will get to that one day.
- At the entrance of the club,
you usually have like a
literal poster that says,
who has the most amount of shime,
which is girls that
come in and choose you,
as like their daddy, basically.
They come in, they wanna sit with you.
- Did you have to use the word daddy?
- What's the equivalent in English?
- Like honey.
- Daddy for sure.
- It's easy money.
- Exactly.
- Would you call him daddy?
- No.
- You're asking the wrong person.
- Okay, carry on, carry on.
- Oh, yeah daddy, anyway.
- So yeah, they display
that, because as I mentioned,
the value for host club is also elevated
by what kind of person you have there.
So some clubs they have this one host
who's like the industry head, like top.
If he moves, it's like,
good example would be League of Legends
professional scene.
- Now you're talking my language.
Do you mean at any sport?
- Man, shut up, let me
talk about the one I know.
- So for example,
if Doublelift changed teams,
who's gonna follow him?
The fans.
And in League of Legends,
professional scene,
the fans make up the entirety, merch,
filling the stage, generally
all the hype of the fort.
So it's the same with host clubs.
- So people aren't loyal to the host club,
they're loyal to the host?
- Well, depends, some host
clubs have a huge history
like, Palacina.
They're known to be
fucking industry standard
in terms of being like
a really high end club,
spectacular service and
having the best hosts.
But there are some newbie clubs
that are elevated by perhaps
recruiting these guys
who work at these prestigious clubs
and raise their name value.
- So it's literally like they're trying to
poach the best players at this club?
- Yeah, for sure.
- Man, I guess all this
anime ranking system,
which is based off the host.
- It comes off the host industry.
- It's strange in Japan,
how in some ways they don't,
like the work culture is so against
ranking anyone against each other,
but then there's certain
industries where it's like,
you're ranked against everyone.
If you fail you're fucking eliminated.
- I mean Japanese schools
do that shit as well.
Like an end of year exam.
And like two weeks later when
they finished marking it,
this huge fucking...
It's not all schools,
but most schools have
these huge fucking post
that says like here's
the top 100 placements.
- I just realized fucking host club
just sounds like ranked ilo.
(group chattering)
- Technically, Garnt,
you're fucking right.
- But they're not like,
the dichotomies that they have
lifetime contracts, right?
Workers can't be fired from companies
It's just so weird, it's like pick one.
- It's like, okay, so I'm not
gonna get fired from my job
just 'cause I'm a low ranking.
You just literally do it
to make me feel like shit.
That's the only reason.
- So you were number three
out of all this thing.
- For the time being.
- Damn, that's crazy.
- How fast did it take you
to get to number three?
- Years, bro?
- I assume that's difficult, right?
- 'Cause you have to build your clientele.
Like as I mentioned the
tactic that I was employing,
it's not really customer friendly.
Most Japanese ladies are
not used to some guys
with a beard coming up
to them and be like,
why are you here?
Why are you paying money to see guys
when you can just go
to a club or anywhere?
So the people that actually
stuck around to drink with me,
they're like, open-minded people.
They wanted to mostly hear
about my experiences in life.
Living abroad, experiencing,
going to bunch of countries,
having fucked up parties and stuff.
- If you don't mind me asking them,
what is the normal clientele demographic?
- So it really changes, man.
So most people might imagine,
it's like a bachans,
old ladies with rich husbands.
But to your surprise,
you actually get like, early twenties,
like idols and stuff
sometimes, (indistinct)
- I mean, I guess that
kinda makes sense, right?
'Cause in what environment
can an idol just go out
and just be comfortable.
In a normal environment.
- Maybe not like the super popular ones,
but especially like all
the underground idols,
there like a shit load of them.
- There's a shit load of them, bro.
- Where they don't really have
an image to keep, I guess,
as strong as like say age 48 or something.
So they can go to a host club.
- 'Cause as someone who grew up abroad
from Japan, do you think
the host environment
can work in like any other country?
Or is it just like something
that's only in Japan,
and only because of the social structure
- You do that in Turkey,
bro, you'll have a fucking like,
an army of taxi drivers
ready to beat you up,
like literally.
- Why taxi drivers?
- Bro, 'cause they are
like the mafia of Turkey.
(all laughing)
Dude in Turkey they say,
don't fuck with bus drivers
and taxi drivers.
Because they own like a gang,
if you fuck with one of them,
you call up the entire neighborhood.
Dude, I shit you not.
(group chattering)
- This is real though, this is huge
because I don't know if I told you guys,
but like the past three years,
when I go back to Turkey,
I always find this one taxi guy
who can like 'chauffeur' me around.
But that's because Turkish
currency is shit right now,
so I can take cabs anywhere.
But once you're really
good with the taxi guy
and treat them like your
own personal driver,
and you get to experience
what kind of life he lives,
wherever district you go to,
he calls somebody up and says,
what's the next target?
Do you have any customers around here?
Do we direct these people to your way?
Bro, they work like a hive mind, bro.
It's crazy.
- It just sounds
like a bunch of organized assassins.
- Dude, they're insane.
- They'll go bonkers.
- So like, whenever you get into trouble,
you call one of them,
like my main homie.
And then he will call this homie's homie.
And they in 10 minutes
you will have like 30 guys
ready for you.
(all laughing)
I shit you not.
That's the benefit of being-
- What the fuck is going on in Turkey?
- Bro, it's all about
connections and people you meet.
- Why taxi drivers?
- 'Cause they're amazing, bro.
- [Connor] They get every guy.
- They know everybody, bro.
'Cause who talks to customers the most?
Barbers and taxi drivers.
Not in Japan, 'cause they suck here,
but in Turkey like you get on,
first thing they say is like,
what's your religion?
- Why are you here?
- Yeah, why are you here?
- The CIA I slip, Turkish taxi drivers,
that's the real shit.
- Oh, honestly, honestly, honestly,
people don't know about this.
It's fucking underground.
- And John Snowden just
moved to Turkey and like,
all right, now I'm impressed.
(all laughing)
My God, sorry,
I've forgotten completely
where we've gotten to.
That was one of the weirdest
tangents I've ever gone on.
Going back to,
I think we're talking
about before taxi drivers,
what are like some of the
most interesting clients
that you've had?
(group chatter)
Before taxi drivers.
- We were talking about
demographics and shit.
- So you said you had like
really, really young girls,
like in early twenties and stuff
- Yeah, like people
the audience would kill
to drink with, if you'd laid eyes upon.
- Don't mean to brag but...
(group chattering)
- No, the thing is,
our shachou was the
owner of apparel brand.
He knew a little models and stuff.
So he was really well-versed in the whole-
- So he'd invite the
models to come to the club?
- Yeah, he would invite
people he works with,
who he works with to the club.
And then, we would have a
jolly good time together.
- Who were like some of the most, I guess,
memorable ones you had?
'Cause I'm sure you've
met like a wide array
of different characters.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, honestly the young girls,
not really memorable because
at the end of the day
if you live in Japan your whole life
and never left the country,
with the lack of life experience,
there's not much I can gain out of you.
It's mostly me talking about myself
and like the party like that blah, blah.
But it gets old after a while.
So the best client that ever had,
and I still do see sometimes to this day
is a very senior lady,
who is just there for
gaining more friends in life.
Someone who's like above 60.
She doesn't need to do anything,
she's like chauffeured in a Bentley.
She comes to the place
in a chauffeured manner,
comes in, spends money, leaves.
But the stories she has is something.
Spending time with her is...
That's when I feel like
actually doing something.
- So that's what you
enjoy about being a host,
I guess is, hearing interesting stories.
Hearing about life experiences.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean, it gets boring after a while,
just talking about yourself.
What the fuck?
- A lot of things just fell there.
- Maybe I drink something.
(all laughing)
I'm sorry my patreon, I'm not-
- I guess it makes sense, right?
'Cause there's only so many times
where you can tell your life story
and get it the same (speaking
in foreign language)
I get that, yeah.
That would get boring.
- What do you think makes
a successful host then?
Is it the gimmick?
Do you need like a unique gimmick
to be like a successful host?
- Well, looks definitely don't mean shit,
in the grand scheme of things.
- Which is weird because you'd think
that that would mean something, right?
- A lot of comments on my YouTube video.
They were like, well, some of
these guys aren't beautiful.
It's like, yeah, they don't have to be.
- That has like a surface
level value to it.
Like first impression.
- First impression, yeah.
- But after that, it's
all about your demeanor,
the way you carry yourself forward,
how you present yourself.
And most people employ what
I just told you guys about,
which is don't talk about personal stuff,
compliment them, beautiful eyes, whatever.
And then try to get them
to like you in that way.
Everybody has their own
shtick, to a certain degree.
- So you'd say like
personalities way more?
- Yeah, 100%.
- Like in real life,
- Yeah, like in real life.
- This is where I wanna mention my,
most respected hosting related person,
which is Roland.
- He's like top of the top.
- He's not even a host anymore.
- Not anymore, he was.
- Explain what role in
this to the audience.
- So to those that don't know,
please, this is Roland, check him out.
But to those who don't know,
Roland started off as a
host in his early twenties.
(all laughing)
- You got to like plan out this sips, man.
Do it when someone else
is talking or something.
You do realize there are people
who listen to audio only, right?
So there's just like a long pause.
- Well then you fill the gap for me.
(all laughing)
- But you do it sort
of like out of nowhere,
(Jan and Joey shouting)
Okay, yeah, so roll on.
- So he started as a normal host,
he climbed his way through.
He went to Palacina
and then he went in his own
club called (indistinct)
Basically, this guy
proved to the world that
hosting is not something
that only dumb asses
who fail at life do.
It's what shrewd businessman can do
to leverage their position.
- 'Cause he's like super smart, right?
Not just like street smart,
but he's also like
actually like book smart.
- Exactly, but the fact that
he always keeps his own hosting values,
which is how arrogant he is,
the way he brings himself forward.
Like he always knows and shows
that he's the best looking
and the smartest guy in the room.
You know in Japanese culture,
it's always about like,
(indistinct)
Being below the other person at all times.
- Being humble.
- Exactly.
But (speaking in foreign language)
he takes this and then flips on the,
and then basically like it mounts on you.
And like these poor Japanese businessmen,
they're just like, oh my God,
they don't know how to handle it.
- So, basically he's a Jan.
- He's a fucking Jan.
- He's like a gig of Jan.
- I'm surprised you guys
didn't do like collab
or do anything with him yet.
- Why would he give a shit?
- Yeah, why would he give a shit about us?
- I don't even know if he speaks English.
- Well, the thing is,
diversifying into the foreign market.
- I mean, I'd like to
do something with him...
(group chatter)
'Cause I've known about
him for such a long time,
because at one point,
especially when he had just
come out of the host business
and started his own
company Ranisha like that,
he was everywhere on Japanese TV.
He's probably like,
I would say on the grander
scale of Japanese entertainment,
he's probably the most
well-known host ever.
- Absolutely, bro, absolutely.
- So like, it was just really interesting.
'Cause I read up on him as well.
'Cause I was like, who's
this fucking Roland guy.
And I read up on him and he's like, yeah,
like you can tell this guy is just like,
so fucking street smart when
it comes to like business
and stuff like that.
He clearly knows his
way on making himself.
- Well, you got to be street
smart to be a fucking host.
- But I think as Jan said,
it completely flipped
society's impressions
of what hosts can be.
Because yeah, as you said,
to everyone hosts were just
like good-looking dudes
who have nowhere to go
and just like wanna talk to chics.
- Scam a girl for money, blah, blah.
But, I think Roland
completely flipped that over
and was like, no, you
don't have to be like that
to be a successful host.
If anything, doing that, doesn't
make you a successful host.
- Exactly.
And the most like impressive
thing about Roland is
the way he approaches his customers.
As I mentioned, my main
impression is through him.
Well, I discovered him
after I became a host,
to be honest with you.
But then I discovered the way
I do things similar to him,
which is,
- Be arrogant.
- Be arrogant about yourself
because I know for a fact
that within the entire
district of Ikebukuro,
I have more 'life experience',
than anybody that you can meet there.
But with that as a leverage,
what I try to do is,
levitate the other person.
I want the customer to leave my presence
with a feeling of rejuvenation,
something like...
(all laughing)
- The words you are using.
- You say it as if they
came out of a baptism.
It's not a religion, here.
- I'm a new man.
- Where do you think life
experience comes from?
Where do you think you
learn life experience?
- Life.
- In general,
where do you think it comes from?
- Well, just tackling new
activities, in different places,
with people who we have never met before.
If you've stayed in Japan your whole life,
never left the neighborhood
versus someone who has traveled the world.
Especially like if you live
in the vicinity of Europe.
You can just go to like
20 different countries.
Easily.
- That's the good thing about Europe.
'Cause like, to me,
the concept of driving to
another country is so fun.
Because like, Japan you can't do that,
Australia you sure as shit can't do that.
I can't even drive to the next state.
So it's so cool to think
that in such a small space,
there are so many cultures.
So I've always been jealous of like,
especially you guys.
Like the fact that you
guys lived in the UK
and didn't explore all of Europe.
- I've been to a lot of Europe.
- Yeah, what's your
favorite European country?
- That's the way to do it though.
- Austria.
- Austria?
- Austria is like chilled Germany.
(all laughing)
- I'm sure the Germans will
be thrilled to hear that.
- Germans know they love their all.
Austria's got like
everything that Germany has,
but it's so chilled.
- Where's your favorite that's not Turkey?
- Oh, man, Czech Republic.
- Czech Republic is fun
- I've heard brilliant
things about Czechs.
- I'm rubbing my foot against your leg.
- It's all good, man.
(all laughing)
- He's getting into it.
- Bro, Prague, man.
It's middle of Europe.
Berlin is like 500 bucks away
so you can techno clubs whenever.
- In the UK, people are obsessed
with getting cheap holidays.
So I ended up going to
like really odd places
that you would like never
go to for any normal reason.
'Cause someone was like,
well going a wedding there.
Like I went to Malta.
The four Malta viewers
who are watching this,
- Say whoa!
- We're four.
- A cheap holiday, right?
(all laughing)
- It's like, it's a pretty cool place.
- You could go to a travel
agent sometimes in England
and they're just like
these certain countries.
- We have a country, you might know,
- There is a good deal going on.
There's a good deal going on
in this country right now.
- I feel it's the best though, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Cyprus, Greece-
- Because those aren't countries.
- Cyprus, fake Turkey
- Yeah, yeah
- Well Cyprus's history is
like half Greek, half Germany.
- It feels like there's
some beef going on.
- (indistinct) attack you guys,
we should probably cut that one out now.
- Ah, that's fine, they'll understand.
- We shit on countries all the time, bro.
- That's your beef.
- You're the on that said, not us.
- Well I'm Turkish, that's why.
- Well, you're Turkish so it's all good.
- So just look forward to
a lot of people from Cyprus
coming into your chat to just
remind you of what you said.
- Come to my Twitch
stream just to shit on me,
welcome guys, let's go.
- But like that's the thing, right?
That's what I like about Europe though.
It's because there's the
countries that everyone knows
that everyone wants to go to.
Like, Italy, France, Spain.
The ones that you think
of when you think Europe.
But then you realize that
there are so much more,
and even these tiny countries,
there's so much like unique
culture just within that.
So for me, it's like,
I wanna try and go to as much
of Europe as I possibly can.
The problem is my entire life,
it's been on the other
side of the fucking world.
- It's like, the grass is
greener on the other side road.
Because for me, I never
fully took advantage of that
because I was like so
obsessed with exploring Asia.
Like I just love like
exploring Asian countries
that I just didn't realize what
the fuck was in my backyard
my entire life.
- My parents took me,
I didn't have a choice.
But I probably wouldn't have gone,
I would definitely gone
to Asia or America.
- 'Cause like for me, I
grew up in I'm just like,
oh mom and dad, are we going on holiday?
Oh, is it Thailand again?
Oh, we are gonna see grandma again
for like the say, the
20th time in my life.
For me like being 20 years old.
(all laughing)
That was like holidays for me.
- That makes sense.
- But like getting back to...
where did we get to
the fucking host thing?
- So you were talking about
the very rich 60 year old.
- Oh yeah man.
Like honestly, I don't know
if she will ever watch this,
but what I really like about her,
it's how seductive she is.
in the way she just like conducts herself.
- I feel that was a better
choice for words there,
to be honest.
- She is though.
She would just ask me like,
Hey Jan, how was your day?
But like the way she does it,
the way she moves her body,
the way she has eye contact,
like she just...
It takes someone who's aware
of every single muscle
movement in their body.
And I just watch her and
I just like melt away.
I'm like, keep talking to me please.
- And to be fair,
I guess 60 year old Japanese women
look a lot younger than 60 year olds-
- That is true.
60 year old Japanese women
can look 30 if they wanna.
- Bro, she looks magnificent.
You would barely think she's over 35.
- Oh, he's turned on the host mode.
- She would always come-
- Does she have pretty eyes?
- She's beautiful, bro.
She's just actually beautiful.
- Is that what you tell her?
- Obviously, I always tell her like-
- Clearly, he actually feels that way.
- He actually brings it up poignantly.
- It's not like you're
describing the love of your life.
What's going on?
- Since I also respect her a lot because
for experiences in general,
she has a lot to talk about.
But also the fact that she's
such self-aware person,
who's able to make me feel the way I do.
That's something, you know.
It's stuff like that, that
the idol girls can't do.
I speak to these girls
and I just feel like,
wow, you're fucking stupid, aren't you?
(all laughing)
It's just the truth though.
Sometimes when you're speaking...
- I mean, you must've met
some really stupid girls
if you're saying that.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I don't mean it that way,
I didn't mean it that way.
That came out wrong.
(Jan speaking in foreign language)
Let me explain myself,
let me explain myself.
I'm not calling you stupid.
I mean, you've met a lot of stupid people.
So like your level of stupid
must be like really, really stupid
because you've met all
sorts different people.
I realized that came out very wrong.
- He saved it at the last moment.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not calling Jan stupid.
- I would like to say we do
not have our mans right now.
This is not our man.
- Come on, guys.
- I'm in the corner over here.
(all laughing)
I'm literally backed into a corner.
- You just pulled out
the fucking black hole
spinning the inter-stellar
at the last moment.
- I pulled out.
- Sometimes you're on
a night out with a bro
and you're just like, you know what?
If you're doing this, I'm sorry, man,
I don't have your back man.
Sorry
(group chattering)
Sometimes you're like,
yeah, got your back,
anything you do, Joey.
Sometimes just like-
- I was getting ready to
call my taxi driver home.
(all laughing)
- Dude, please anything
about the tax driver.
I'd rather you call the CIA.
(all laughing)
- So like, okay, so you
were the third best host.
Like how much grinding did you need to do?
How much grinding on the
ladder did you need to do, man?
- Oh, fuck all.
- What constitutes as
grinding in the host world?
- See, that's a good thing.
So I guess I can go
into like the downsides
of being a host at this point.
Tying it back down to why
people even go to the host club.
So the reason is because
you can only find a host
in the host club.
Why?
Because the guy is working
in the evening until morning sometimes.
He sleeps, he wakes up,
he does his daily chores
and then he has to go to work
again and it's like 5:00 PM.
So that's why the only
time you can see a host
is at the club.
But as a successful host,
who has bunch of clients
that they're juggling,
you have to go to lunches,
you have to go to their birthdays,
you have to go to anniversary.
So whatever the sorts, to Disneyland.
And you have to spend a
lot of money on gifts.
- When you go on a date with
them outside of the host club,
you pay for everything, right?
- Yeah, during the day
when you see them, I mean,
I don't do that,
'cause I never went on a date
with a girl during the day
because I just didn't care.
But number one guy,
that's the difference between
me and the number one guy,
'cause that's what he did.
He would sleep like two hours
and then you would go on a
date with a girl to Disneyland,
act like he's having fun,
buy shit at the Disney store.
- It's literally like school.
It's like, if you do extra
curricular activities,
you're going to be like placed top.
- But you have to, 'cause it's
like a give and take, right?
The more you invest in the
girls that you hang out with,
the more they wanna give back.
But that's not what I was interested in.
I always made my interest
very clear from the beginning,
which is why the fuck are you here?
(all laughing)
- I'm just gonna click date over.
- It's literally just
sounds like Persona 5.
You like bring a gift,
the social rank increases sometimes.
(all laughing)
- Does your mind just connect
everything with the Gacha
in general?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Persona 5 is not Gacha.
- I know, but their system is very well...
(Joey speaking in foreign language)
- Yeah, it is.
It's like you go on a date...
If you want the girl
to fight alongside you
during the battle,
then you gotta be nice to
them in the real world.
- This is a simulation.
- Persona 5 is a host simulation.
- Discovery of the century.
God damn.
- Jeez.
'Cause when you said gift,
like giving gifts and stuff like that,
and the host has to give gifts,
I can't imagine how many
gifts you have to give.
Considering Japan's gift giving
culture is already insane.
- Its bad shit crazy, bro.
The number one host, he would tell me,
depending on the month,
on how well the stars
align and how many people
have anniversaries and shit in that month,
he might spend up to 70%
of his income of that month
on just gifting shit, going
to places, doing shit.
- I guess that's like an
investment for him for sorts.
(group chattering)
- Yeah, and then when your birthday comes
and then you're calling like
14 girls to your birthday
and they're all paying like...
(group chattering)
- That's the payout
day, that's his payday.
- I saw advertisements of
one host that he'd made
over $100,000 in one
night from his birthday.
- Easy bro, easy.
- $100,000
- From gifts or?
- Just from people
coming, gifts, everything.
- Champagne tower that they build for you.
- That's a natural person
who wishes that birthday was two days.
- The one guy who's like,
can I have a birthday month please?
- I've got 24 hours in my birthday.
Like, I guess I'm not sleeping tonight
because that's like an extra
$10,000 I could be earning.
- One thing I remember definitely being a,
definite downside I'd say, is that,
a lot of them seemed like they had
developed an alcohol addiction of sorts
because you're forced to
drink almost every day.
- Can we go over the
whole drinking culture?
- Sure.
- Let's do it, let's do it.
- It seems insane.
(group chattering)
(all laughing)
- One thing that I found
really weird is that
they were all just talking to each other
and joking about how they had all been
throwing up that morning,
'cause they were so hangovered.
And then I was like, how often do you,
I'm not sure it was in the video.
So how often do you like get
so drunk that you throw up?
He was like, yeah,
three, four times a week.
Three, four times a week, just
throwing up from drinking.
That's insane.
- How much do you have to drink
on a regular working night?
- For me it was mostly
just about how much I want.
- So say if like one of your clientele's
buys you a drink, can you say no to it?
- Exactly.
The way the structure within
the host club works is
if you're the one coming
in with a client already
that you met, you sit at
the table side like us.
And across from us, you
would have a helping person
who would be the one arranging the drinks,
pouring shit for you.
The peasantry work.
Stuff I haven't done in ages.
- Was he a host himself?
Or is it just...
- Yeah, they're all
hosts, they're all hosts.
- So it's somebody who's
below down in the rankings?
- I mean, if you don't
have a girl for yourself
then might as well help
your bro kind of thing.
And your specific job is to just drink
so that your homie doesn't have to drink,
so he can persuade the
girl to buy more drinks
so that you can drink kind of thing.
- So he literally gets
paid to drink your drinks?
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't know if we've
said this in the episode,
but like the way that hosts make money
is from them buying drinks, right?
- Yeah, for sure.
And food too, bro.
- So you get a cut of every single drink,
or how does it work?
- At the end of the night,
depending on the payment,
but usually you get 40% of the spending.
- Of the gross spending?
- So if I buy a $15 drink, you might get-
- Yeah, if the girls spent $1,000-
- Yoh, why did you choose $15?
- People buy $10 drinks, you get $4?
- $10,000 is a more realistic number.
Then it would be like 400
bucks that you will make.
Just drink it with somebody.
- Wait, why are you hiring host?
Just hire like a fucking
Ozzie in the backroom.
- See, does the Ozzie speak Japanese?
(all laughing)
That's why at the
beginning of the episode,
I said he could be a great host.
- Going with how this story has gone,
I wouldn't be a great host.
I'd be a great host who helps
his homie finish his drink.
I would basically be
an extra lever for you.
- So this helper guy,
he will sit at the table
while you're talking and
he will drink your drink,
that this girl has bought for you.
- He can talk, right?
- Of course he talks.
You have to make good conversation.
'Cause I was doing that
for two years, bro.
All you have to do it is
just make conversation.
- But like how do you not
step on the other guy's toe?
So if it's his girl, it's his girl.
- Well, sometimes some
treacherous shit happens.
- [All] Whoa!
- Backstabbing.
- Do you have any examples or stories?
- Yeah, of course.
- Do share.
- Well, mostly it happened
between me and the number one guy
of the place I worked at.
'Cause we're really close homies.
'Cause number one guy was
very interesting, man.
This guy, he was a normal salary man
in the architecture business,
earning a good salary for
world standard until he was 27.
And one day he said, fuck this,
I'm just gonna become a host.
Literally like he just gave up everything.
He said, I don't care about it anymore.
I'm just gonna become a host
and he's fucking successful at it.
The dude is genius.
He's very smart, very good
looking, feminine as fuck,
but that's just,
- That's how it works.
- That's just the way it is.
But this guy, for example,
what were we talking about by the way?
- The drinks are in him.
- Did you ever have like,
'cause obviously you have
the helper and the main guy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure.
So when this guy brings in...
There would be evenings
where number one guy
would invite like seven,
eight different girls
at the same time.
So we went out of like-
- How do they not get pissed off?
- See, they can't say anything.
What are the girls gonna say?
"I'm mad that you're so successful."
- The girls can say like
I'm buying you drinks,
so give me more attention.
- Well, he says, "well, sucks for you.
Other girls want me too.
If you don't want it, get the fuck out."
That's what they say bro.
- What they would do is they'd be like,
"Hey, if you want your turn,
you gotta buy me the champagne thing,
that cost like $10,000."
- Yeah, exactly.
You want have to stay,
champagne is right there,
we can to pop it and I'll stay.
- It's literally like some kind
of like squid game-ish thing
where they like putting
them against each other.
- But in the essence of it,
it's taking advantage kind of thing.
- It's absolutely taking advantage.
- But in the grand scheme of things,
the girls are the ones who
decide to come back to it.
- Yeah, that's true.
I guess they're not helping themselves.
- You're not tying them down.
- Strange.
Don't know, don't know,
in some ways, that's
one way to look at it,
but I'm sure it's way
deeper than that, right?
I feel like, yeah, I don't know.
- It depends on the person, I guess.
- I mean, it just feels
like the entire host culture
and entire host world just works
in obviously different social rules
and different social values.
I mean, none of them would
probably be in a host club
if that wasn't the case, right?
- We are four guys talking
about why women might go to it.
We don't understand it as
well as we think we do.
So I feel like that,
I don't wanna come off as
a misogynistic or anything.
I'm sure there's a lot more layers to it
that we understand it, I
don't understand the culture.
- We're obviously just
talking from like a surface.
- I honestly just find it fascinating.
- Didn't they go over it though.
(group chattering)
- But I'm sure not all girls
are like that though, right?
- In what sense?
- Like why they come back.
- I'm sure there's a lot more to it.
You know, it's one of
those things as well.
And I don't know, I feel like as well,
because I guess misogyny
in Japan is like a thing
like a bit more than the
West, I'd probably say.
I mean the rules are
structured around it, right?
And the laws as well.
- The interesting thing about
that is so in any culture,
whether Japanese or whatever,
girls are attracted towards
what's perceived as an alpha.
Someone who seems to
dominate the environment,
someone who seems like
they're on top of things.
(speaking in foreign language)
So in terms of the hosting
industry in itself,
it's made so that,
if it's a girl that you
might've just coming over,
everybody around you,
including the shachou,
the owner of the business, will
do everything in their power
to make you look like the
rockstar of the business,
for the time being.
Because they understand
that if they do that,
the girls will be like,
"Oh my God, the guy I've chosen,
he fucking owns the place."
The little owner of the
bar is bending over,
doing back flips just to please my homie.
So I must have chosen the right guy.
- Full on act, it's just all an act.
- Well, it's not though.
The thing is at least the way I act it,
- Your act comes from some kind
of basis of you as a person.
I'm sure all the other
hosts do that, right?
- Yeah, sure.
- How much of the hosts
have a genuine personality
behind their character
and how much is just
like completely made up?
- That depends from person to person.
- I'm sure you've seen both cases now.
- Of course, of course.
Some of them really try to play it up.
- And it's just not them at all?
- Yeah, not at all.
But sometimes, I mean, like piggy boy
that you went on a date with.
That guy, bro.
- It was really bizarre
because it didn't quite
come across in the video,
'cause obviously it was
cut in like five minutes,
like the whole part of it.
But he had this one girl in that video
who we blurred out, who
is like obsessed with him.
But like, he didn't give
her the time of day.
Like he barely gave any attention to her.
- Yeah, of course, that's
what she likes, bro.
- It's just so weird watching it.
It was like, he literally
couldn't give a fuck.
And she was like, I'm gonna marry him.
And he's like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it was so it was so
strange, wasn't it Mayleen?
Like watching this guy...
(group chattering)
Do you remember how obsessed this girl was
about the main host and he
just didn't give a fuck?
- Yeah.
- And it was like
she bought me the champagne
because he was like,
oh, I wanna impress this guy.
God knows how much she
spent on that champagne
'cause the cheapest one I saw
was like $5,000 or something.
- Dollars?
- Yeah, dollars.
So I don't wanna know how much she spent
just to impress him for like one second.
It didn't even seem like he gave a fuck.
- Well, from what I'm hearing right now,
I'd say like the closest comparison
I think of in the West is,
people maybe pay for like an experience,
if they have like a really weird
fetish or something, right?
And it seems like in Japan,
this is just like the
social fetish in a way
where it's just,
they're paying for like
a certain experience
that maybe they can't
see out in normal life.
- It was cool on the surface.
- Why are you laughing?
- It's really true though.
(group chattering)
- He just realized that he
worked for a social fetish.
I think that's what he realized.
- I realized that I'm
running my own fetish too
at the same time.
- It's an ego-stroke, right?
- It's not like I don't enjoy it.
- Bro, is there a bigger ego stroke
than being paid to have people talk like-
- Yeah, exactly.
- People pamper you.
- But like my general
impression of it when I left,
'cause you have all this
fucking anime around a host club
and you hear about host clubs,
oh, they are so cool.
You're thinking this is kind of like cool.
When I left I was like fuck,
this is depressing as fuck.
I'd say like most of the clients there
seemed like depressed.
It was hot.
- The hosts or
the people coming in?
- Where the fuck
did you got to, bro?
- Some of the hosts
and some of the girls.
- Where the fuck did you go to, man?
- I just felt like they
would just describe it.
They had like nothing else to do.
Like it was, I don't know,
for me it was kind of like, oh God!
- I'm sure for some girls
though, that is the case.
And I think that's why
they go to host clubs.
It's because that's the only
place where, as you said,
they've been shit on the entire day,
they just want someone
to make them feel good.
- And the (indistinct)
of this fucking club,
they got to deal with
me pointing the camera
in their fucking face, I felt so bad.
You think being awkward is fine?
Jesus Christ.
- Maybe they were only depressed
in front of the camera.
- That might've been it.
- It could've been.
- Like cool, the one time I get privacy,
this dude has a camera.
- You disagree with that
or you think it's all like fun?
- No, I agree with you bro.
'Cause one thing that I
have to always remember is,
the customers that I
attract versus the average
is very different.
- I guess you're not attracting
the same type of people
that I was being introduced to.
- Dude, none of my customers
are miserable fucks.
- I met one person on video
who could speak English
and she was super chill,
she was really cool.
Really, really nice.
- Maybe they were miserable
because they couldn't talk to you.
- But I just saw how they interacted
'cause I was getting like
live translations in my ear
the whole time.
And I was like watching it
and it was like, I was like...
- Was it like the stuff
they were talking about
was depressing or?
- It was just kind of how like,
- Or just the atmosphere?
- The atmosphere, you
know, don't get me wrong.
The club was going wild
but like sometimes they would say things,
and I was like, Jesus Christ.
Like, they would say
something that was like,
they were trying to like, I don't know,
they were trying to go for something.
And then the guy was like (mumbles)
And I was just like, oh, fuck.
Like watching car crashes or something.
It was just like, oh my God.
- It's like, try not
to cringe compilation.
- It was you know.
It's weird.
- It's interesting.
It is a weird world.
- Well, strange.
- What's like some of
the weirdest you've seen?
- I'm sure you got stories
that they ask for that.
(Jan sighs)
(all laughing)
That you're allowed to tell, obviously.
- Buddha, get ready.
(all laughing)
- Keep in mind we have to air
this to like a million people.
What you can say and not
have the yuckers up our ass
or whatever.
He's like filtering himself.
- Like, family-friendly stories, right?
- No, no, no, no.
I mean, look, when people
think crazy host stories,
they're gonna think of some crazy shit.
- We're not on fucking BBC.
- Yeah, but also you have to
think about the current people
who employ me as well.
They might see this shit and be like,
oh, wow, this is the
guy I always trust with.
- Be as generic as possible.
- Okay, some generic things
you've seen in the host industry
or some dodgy things that
go on at the host industry.
- Dodgy things.
- Or maybe something you
personally experienced
that you thought was a bit dodgy.
- Oh, well I guess, this
is an interesting one.
So the way they do their
(speaking foreign language)
in Japanese.
So this is the way you
actually boost your numbers
within the industry.
So shime is, as I mentioned in
the beginning of the episode,
this is when you have
people choose their daddy.
The more people choose as to your daddy,
your rank gets higher, billboard.
So people notice you more.
So one way to do that is go to other clubs
like Kyabakura, like
female oriented clubs,
as your host boys.
- Like girls bars or something
- Exactly.
And give them your vote
and then tell them,
this is where I work at.
You got to come here then vote for me.
And they're like, all right, sure.
And then they come vote for you.
- So like presidential campaigns?
- It's like politics.
- This is literal politics right now.
- Well, yeah, I guess,
if you say it that way.
- Do you have like a tag
line and shit like that says
'Jan, I will as you
what you're doing here.'
- I am Jan, my name is Jan.
(Joey laughing)
- Wait, so did you have
to do that as well?
Like why would you have
to go to like girls bars
and kind of stuff like that and be like...
- A lot, dude, like the shachou
would just take all of us,
the people who bailed that night
or the people who are chilling
with other girls that night,
late into the evening
because host club finished
at like 12:00 PM, let's say.
Then we would have like a, subsidiary bar.
- Why does it close so early?
Why does it close to 12:00?
- Laws, bro.
We just take you to a different venue.
And at that bar it's still same shit.
Everything is expensive as fuck,
but you get to just be a bit more relaxed
and then more intimate let's say.
And at that place, if you're
staying there for long,
shachou would come there and be like,
"Yo guys, we're going somewhere."
And get the boys and go to
a club, let's say after.
It could be like Kyabakura
or like whatever establishment
you can think of in Tokyo.
And then the shachou
would pay for everything.
I've seen shachou pay up
to like $6,000, $7,000
one evening for like
three, four guys total.
He would just shell the fuck out.
- But I suppose like
considering the amount of money
that hosts make anyway,
that's like a walkover.
- Yeah, but the guy doesn't care, bro.
He's chilling, man, he's chilling.
- So you would do that
and you would go around
and interact with the girls
at those establishment?
- Yeah, supposedly.
- To basically be like,
hey, when you come to my
club next time, choose me.
- Well, not when, but like,
you're coming next week, right?
(all laughing)
- It's not a suggestion.
- It's more like,
- It's a command.
(Jan speaking in foreign language)
- Right, right, right.
- I'm popping this bottle for you today,
so you're coming next week Tuesday, right?
- So, what happens if they don't come?
- I mean, nothing.
It's not like I'm gonna call
the Turkish taxi drivers.
(all laughing)
- So if you don't vote for me,
I got a lot of taxi drivers
on the line right now.
- We're on the plane right
now, Jan, we're coming.
- And they're not Japanese.
- That's not what's gonna happen.
But if you know anything about Japan,
verbal agreements mean a lot.
In Japan rather than paper signing,
most deals are done
through verbal agreements.
That's because-
- Is that true?
I think a lot of things in
Japan are done on paper.
I mean from my experience at least.
- I mean, that's also
true, but if you look-
- I think socially speaking.
- Socially and traditionally, for example,
a lot of verbal stuff
holds more value to it,
especially if you're like-
- It's all about respect.
- If you're from like a
renowned family, for example,
and you don't like uphold your promise,
you risk losing that
reputation for your family
or your family will whip you, bro.
- But I mean, that was
back in the day, right?
Not now.
- Even now, bro.
- Even now?
- There's just a lot of big
families still to this day.
A lot of people who
wanna respect their like,
you know yeah.
I mean, not that many anymore,
but depending on like the,
for example,
if you look at like really
family owned businesses,
that's how it functions.
Like for example, the
people who make like,
(indistinct)
- The calligraphy.
- Like calligraphy pens.
Made out of rare whatever the fuck hide
or whatever the fuck
- You really know your shit, Jan.
- I don't know man, I'm
just giving you examples.
- Jan describing a girl
versus Jan describing a pen.
(all laughing)
- Yo, she was elegant,
moved all of her muscles,
made me melt.
And I saw this fucking pen
that was made out of a pair
of whatever the fuck animal,
yeah whatever the fuck.
Imagine you're like the supplier
of this hide for this pen.
And then you're dealing
with the people who make
the holding part, the wooden shit.
You don't make wood paper contracts,
you make a verbal contracts.
Why, because your relationship
date back to like 150 years.
That's what I'm talking about.
- But I mean, is that the same
as making a verbal agreement
at a girl's bar?
- Now that you've mentioned it
- For them to come the next day, right?
Like I don't there's many girls
in a Kyabakura who are like,
oh fuck, I better go to this club.
I don't want my family on my ass.
- A part of it does translate though.
- I'm sure it does, but
not to the same capacity.
- No, not to the same capacity,
not in the same respect values,
but in terms of like,
if you're like a renowned
person in your bar
and then you make a promise
and you don't protect that
or make that come true,
other people that are gonna
see you as some lying bastards.
- So you just get outed from
the industry then I guess.
- Well not outed but...
- I guess bad rumors
will spread or anything.
- Yeah, like who is she to make promises?
- I guess, yeah because
it's such a small industry.
- Everybody knows each other.
- If word gets around.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I was sucking Roland's
dick the entire time, but
- Literally or figuratively?
- Fuck!
- Doesn't matter, bro.
(group chattering)
(all laughing)
- So anyhow, I know a few people who have,
had fun with him and drank
with him in the past.
So if I really, really, really wanted to,
I could still get a message across to him.
I could reach out to
his SNS much as saying,
some dude called Jan
is saying this to him.
I would make it happen.
That's how close contact
this entire industry is.
Doesn't matter if you're
the most renowned host or...
- Sounds like Turkish taxi drivers to me.
- Now that you mentioned it bro,
shit, what should I do,
fly out my homies here
and establish my own network?
- All the hosts are Turkish taxi drivers.
- Dude, honestly like
where do people talk?
Host clubbing.
How much shit does Jan
know of all of his clients.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I'm curious about how,
you mentioned your club
and then you've mentioned
this other famous ones.
- Yes, sir.
- So first of all,
how long have clubs been around?
Host clubs, sorry, in Japan.
And two, what's the difference
between like the older ones
and the new ones?
- How long have they been around?
That's your first question, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like as a subculture.
- Yeah.
- Dozens of years bro.
- Thousands of years?
- Dozens of years.
- A while, man, a while.
Host club culture has
been around for a while.
But when it started popping off,
I would say in like the last 15 years.
- It seems like a really new thing.
When you look at it from the surface.
- To a certain degree.
- I think Japan has become more of London,
because of the technology and...
- When did their birth
rate start declining?
- About 10, 15 years ago.
- That makes sense.
- That makes sense, that makes sense.
- So what's the difference then
between like a club that's
been around 50 years,
how do they do business?
What's the difference
between that and like how,
say a club that popped
up like two weeks ago?
- Well, as I was saying, for
example, a club like Palacina,
that hosted one of the most
legendary hosts of all time,
like Roland.
Just by hosting them there,
they can up their name
without them meaning.
People who don't know
anything about clubs,
they get the club's name into
their ear, through social.
Anything goes on like Twitter
news, Ryan news, anything.
They kind of see that exposure, club name.
- I mean, it says a lot
that I know Palacina
even though I've never, I
don't even know where it is.
- And there's these fucking
vans that drive around Shinjuku.
- Oh, yeah, those mad vans.
- They just fucking screech
this horrible music out
with like these-
- Oh, that's what they are?
- Some of them are host clubs.
- I didn't know.
- It's awful, it's the
most horrible sound.
- It's a fortune to get those too.
- Yeah, I can imagine.
- The car with your face on
it and just waving money.
- No, all I hear sometimes
are just like the,
the political people would
just shouting shit out.
- It's just base boosted speakers,
you can't even hear what they're saying.
It's been loud, it's so annoying.
- There was also the one that goes around
in Shinjuku and Shibuya all the time
that's like (singing in foreign language)
- I can't imagine being
the truck driver, man.
Like how long is this shit?
- I have actually seen,
when one of the vanilla trucks went past,
I was like, I wanna get a look
of the actual driver's face.
Yo, he looked brain dead as fuck.
He was literally like...
- It's gotta be that meme from
Caroline, the guy on the PC,
like...
- That's what he looked like.
- So go ahead about the
difference between the clubs.
- Yeah, so what would you say?
Is it like a difference in service
or like the way that they
do it or like the rules?
- I'll say the main difference is, cut.
(Joey laughing)
- So dramatic, so dramatic.
I need to pee as well actually.
- This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Connor, what is that special
wooden box you've got there?
- Thought you'd never asked Joey,
this is a special gift just for you.
- Is that a wooden Bokksu?
- It sure is.
- Hold your horses, gentlemen,
what is this Bokksu thing you talk about?
- I'm glad you ask, Garnt.
Let me tell you.
Bokksu's a monthly snack
box subscription service
that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese
snacks and tea pallets.
- [Connor] Bokksu makes such
a perfect and memorable gift
for anyone in your life
who appreciates Japanese
snacks and culture.
Especially during a time
when people aren't able to travel
as easily as they would like to.
- Gentlemen, you know
what's special about Bokksu
this month?
- What is it, Joey?
- Free tickets to Japan.
Bokksu's having a giveaway
where one lucky winner
will win a free ticket to Japan.
That's right and anyone who has subscribed
before December 31st is
automatically entered.
Link is in the description below.
So you can check out
the terms and conditions
and other methods of entry.
- And another thing that
is super special this month
is the wooden box, which is
also known as a kidibako bokksu
which I didn't know about that.
- I knew that.
- What's kidibako?
- Wooden box.
(all laughing)
From now until December 30th,
you can receive your next Bokksu
in a special kidibako wooden
box for an additional $50.
Lovingly crafted in the Koga City, Japan
by Masuda Kidibako.
- So what are you waiting for?
You can use Trash Taste 10
and the link in the description
below to become eligible,
to win the giveaway by
subscribing to Bokksu.
The code will get you 10%
off your subscription.
Don't miss out on this unique opportunity
for anyone who subscribes
until December 31st.
So like I said, get yourself
or a special loved one,
a Kidibako Bokksu and check out the link
for a chance to win a free
trip to Trash Tastes land.
Back to the show.
- So the main difference
between like a new club
that just popped out
versus a club with a long, long history is
how much respect it has from
other clubs surrounding it.
So as I mentioned if you're
like a long time club,
that means you have at least a few people
who either came out of your
club or went to your club
and became really popping
off, went on like news medias,
or just carried your club to the surface.
And that carries a lot of
value in the hosting industry.
- It's weird to me that Japan puts hosts
on this pedestal, but
then you know how it is,
if you're a woman doing the
exact same job reversed,
it's like,
- Oh, she's a whore.
- It's like, you're the scum of society.
It's bizarre really 'cause-
- It is very double standards for sure.
- Even if we had that in the West,
I don't think we'd be
putting the hosts on TV
and stuff like that.
But in Japan, it's just like,
dude, this guy's sick, bro.
He like talks to girls all day.
- [Jan] And he's paid for it.
- The fuck, bro, you're disgusting
It's like the fuck.
I should have mentioned that.
- But I think as well,
that's like going back
to like Roland, right?
Like I think the reason why it
became like that is because,
in a lot of ways it's 'cause of Roland.
- I think it's accepted
that a guy can be like that.
And at least Japanese side here.
That's a character that
like, yeah, this is good.
But if a woman acted the same way-
- I think if there was like a
female equivalent of Roland,
it wouldn't happen the
same way, unfortunately.
- You have good examples of that though.
A lot of huge cosmetic shachous right now
come from Kyabakura background
and stuff like that.
But like you mentioned,
Roland's impact on this
industry is impeccable.
Something you cannot
measure with just numbers.
- Also he sold himself
as a personality on TV.
Whereas we haven't really
had that for the female,
Kyabakura side.
- No, not at all.
- So you join a new club, right?
Let's say you're a rookie,
you're shit at your job,
you're just terrible.
What's the experience I
would have being terrible
in one of the old, amazing,
perfect respected clubs
versus being in a club that's
kind of shit and like small
and like just kind of like...
- Will you even get a job in that sense?
- Let's say you've got it,
and then you start fucking up,
like you couldn't get any clients.
'Cause I can imagine that
they don't treat you...
They're not like, oh,
it's okay, it's okay.
- They use the traditional method.
- But I imagine the one
that's kind of worse off
it's like, oh.
- I mean the best example I can give is,
imagine being in like unknown
ass consulting company
versus being in Boston consulting.
- The pressure...
- That's a very specific example.
- Look, the pressure you
have at Boston consulting,
doesn't derive from
the fact that you suck,
but it's because this is the
company values we uphold.
Are you reaching that standard.
If you're not, we have a
thousand other recruits outside
lining up to take your place, man.
Versus an unknown ass club, it's like,
we could fire you, but
we'll have nobody else.
(group chattering)
That's the difference.
- So like, how dangerous is the industry?
- That's a good question.
- Dangerous?
Well, actually that's a
really great question because,
from the old times, all of the host clubs
are known to have a lot of
violence involved in them.
Meaning if you're not performing
well, if you're slacking,
your boss might kind of slap you around.
- Wait, what do you mean slap you around?
(group chattering)
- Nah, bro, I'm talking
about the you're sleeping
and they'll bash your head and shit.
- Its like Goodfellas.
- Even in my host club, not within there,
but previous to joining there,
I've had stories told to
me from those people there
that they were kind of falling asleep
and then they got smacked
in the head so hard,
that their tooth chipped and shit.
- Just 'cause they were sleeping?
- Yeah, exactly.
Just because they were like
not so responsive and whatnot.
Even within my host club,
we would have meetings
to go over statistics, who's billing well,
who's the good head of bar.
'Cause even if you're not billing,
if you're contributing so
that the girls are drinking
they will respect you.
'Cause that means-
- 'Cause you're doing your job.
- Exactly, that means you
contribute to the actual revenue.
But if you're just like, not
even catching girls outside,
and when the girls sit with you,
you're some boring ass motherfucker,
they're gonna fucking bitch about it.
And that's the main way to make you quit.
It's by putting on the
spotlight and be like,
you fucking suck.
- They just can't tell you to fuck off?
- 'Cause I mean, that's not
the way Japanese people do it.
- They like shame you
publicly until you quit?
- Bro, yeah, honestly yeah.
- That's fucked up, that's so fucked.
- I mean regular companies do that too.
- But that's 'cause they
have lifetime contracts.
(group chattering)
If they're willing to
like slap you in the head,
why aren't they willing to tell you
not to turn up to work tomorrow?
I don't understand.
- I love that.
I was like I have no resistance
to actually smacking the back of the head,
but I don't have the
heart to tell you to quit.
(group chattering)
- The thing is if you prevail
from this agonizing pain,
- That's such bullshit.
- Bro, come on.
It is a real true phenomenon
where if you're strong enough
to prevail this challenge
that's given to you, that
means you could become a man.
- I agree in some sense.
- I don't about that.
- I think that only
works in shounen anime.
- Tell me your pussy ass
excuse, come on, tell me.
(Joey laughing)
- There is a challenge and
there is being beaten up
in your workplace.
Bro, you're not Mike Tyson, bro.
You're not throwing
hands in the club, man.
- Host industry is not
some sugarcoated powder.
- I'm not saying that.
- We're not saying it is.
- We've established
that it's dodgy as fuck
- It is dodgy as fuck
and you have to know
your street knowledge.
If you don't have any street abilities,
you're gonna get fucking bulldozed over.
That's a fact.
- But you're framing it as some form of,
it's a noble challenge,
that one must undertake to become a host.
- Is that the way I'm putting it?
- [Connor] In a sense.
- I'm putting it in a way that
it's like rolling in the mud
and wrestling until one
of them chokes to death.
(all laughing)
That's the kind of challenge
that you have to undertake.
- Did you think that analogy was better?
(all laughing)
- I think it reflects the situation
or at least reflects the
reality of the situation.
- Do you think it's fucked up?
It's fucked up, but you also
think there's a point to it?
- Yeah, absolutely.
No, it's not fucked up, bro.
- No, it's fucked up.
- Look, who am I to judge?
- You literally just said,
you're rolling around the mud until one...
I'm pretty sure, like gladiators did that
back like the Roman Empire.
- But look, in any business
there's a reason as to why
the whole thing transpired
to become what it is.
You have to respect what came before you
and understand why it's the way it is.
That's the whole core of
understanding what a culture is.
- I get that but then there are,
sometimes there are cultures
that should maybe be changed.
- Just because something's
been established
doesn't mean you can't change the rules.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
- I feel Japan-
- I'm sensing some woke bullshit in here.
(group chattering)
- I just think generally
that I understand,
why these kind of stories
can happen in the industry.
I'm not gonna say that is not fucked up.
Jan let's just break this down.
You're literally trying to say that
getting your teeth kicked
in is not fucked up.
- Obviously, no, no, no, no
Obviously, obviously, obviously, see,
- You're saying it's not fucked up
because it happened to my sampya.
- My sincere apologies
for not making this clear.
There is a huge difference
between having a disciplined
way of conducting your business
versus violence.
Because violence is really frowned upon.
No matter what.
(all laughing)
(group chattering)
- Finally a take I can agree with.
- You're right, Jan, water is wet.
- How is like xenophobia
and racism within the host?
- There's plenty of that shit, man.
- Yeah, because I've heard that
a lot of host clubs actually
don't let foreigners in?
- No, no, they don't because like,
what are they gonna do?
- Well, what if they
wanna have a good time
trying to like interact with the locals?
- They can't communicate.
- If you can speak
Japanese and you're fine
they'll let you in?
- If you can speak Japanese
and you're a foreigner,
you have a chance.
- A chance?
- You have a chance?
- That's interesting.
- Survive the beating
and we'll give you a drink.
(all laughing)
- This is the same with almost
all other Japanese businesses
that are nightlife related.
If you're a foreigner, most
likely they'll be like,
and then not accept you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, some restaurants fucking do this,
let alone the night lifestyle
- Going back to the whole
discrimination thing
that I just mentioned,
'cause you're a halfer.
- Am I now?
- Oh, yes you are.
(group chattering)
- Cut back to an hour ago.
- I've seen Joey be in (indistinct) zoo
like 5 billion times.
And from, from what I've seen,
Joey, I'm sure you can
say if I'm right or wrong,
if you don't look a
hundred percent Japanese,
they just assume you're like
foreign just fully foreign.
- 100%
- So how does that, you know,
'cause that comes into
a play a lot in Japan.
So how does it come into
play in a host club?
- How many times will you
(speaking foreign language)
at a host club?
- Every single time.
- Surely they must in
some senses they're like,
oh, you're not Japanese bro.
You're like the gimmick, bro,
you're a foreigner absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah, each time, each time.
- So did you use that to your advantage
or did you like try and fight against it?
- Nope.
As I mentioned to you guys before,
I had no interest in talking to girls
who had no life experience
or who had no interest in life experience.
So I would come across
some people that say like,
I ask them, do you wanna go abroad?
I've been to this country,
wanna know more about it?
And they're like, no, I'm okay
with just staying in Japan.
I'll be like, okay, next guys.
- It's weirdly common.
- It happens a lot, bro, happens a lot.
But I skipped those girls
because I have nothing that
I wanna talk to them about.
But until I find the people
that wanna know more about,
living abroad,
- The worldly things.
- That's when I shine.
- So these girls,
we've established like just how much money
is spent in these host clubs.
Like, how do these clients
have this much money?
Because as we've established,
not everyone is like old, mature,
successful businesses woman.
- How do these women in the early twenties
spend like stupid amounts of money on you?
- So this comes back to the
discussion about the demographic
of the host club.
So most of them are into nightlife.
And nightlife in Japan pays a lot,
like substantial amounts.
So they have a huge amount
of disposable income
or such expenditures.
And that's what they
decide to spend it on.
- I mean like every week it seems like,
X celebrity is caught in a
(indistinct) or a girls bar.
So I mean clearly no
shortage of clientele.
And given the frequency
of these girls bars,
I mean, they're everywhere in town,
they're not struggling.
- It seems like everyone
pays each other back.
- It's just the same mode
of spinning the $50 around.
- It's just like, yeah,
there's a lot of money,
but I'm gonna be paying
that money back to you.
Oh, it's you again.
Now it's your turn to pay me.
- I think a cool experiment would be,
if you leave a little mark
on a thousand yen note
and see if it eventually comes
back into your hand, right?
Like, that could be kind of cool.
- That's a good one.
- I'm sure it happens.
- But the core of the business
does lie in that though.
It's that the nightlife
people support each other.
- Do you have time to spend
the money that you earn
or does it just go back into the industry?
- For sure, bro.
'Cause as I was mentioning,
I don't do this full time.
Like I never did it full time.
- No, I mean, talking about
like hosts in general.
- Yeah like full time hosts.
Do they have enough time to
like spend it on themselves or?
- Look, if you're at like
the top 1% kind of thing,
you barely have time to sleep, honestly.
- Yeah, right?
- Yeah.
- So they just get like no days off
to spend it on themselves?
- I had a few benders
with the number one guy
back in the day and his
day would go like this,
I would see him at the host
club after his hair, makeup.
And he will do his own
makeup in the bathroom
and I would call him all the names I can.
And then once the night starts,
I see him bringing out all
this girls until like midnight.
And then from there he will
take me to the subsidiary bar
where we would drink for
like three, four hours.
And then we would meet up
with another separate group of girls
that are just like the late night crew,
after like 3:00, 4:00 AM,
that just wanna hang
out until like 10:00 AM.
And then we'd just go hard until then.
And then this guy would not
sleep and go for a lunch,
with another girl he's already seeing.
And he would have a lunch with her
and sometimes go to Disneyland and shit,
without sleeping, bro.
- How did this man not
look like a human rat?
- That's why they're all
skinny as shit, dude.
- I did that for one night bro,
and I looked like I'd been hit by a car.
I looked dreadful.
- It's difficult stuff, man.
So he goes to sleep at
like 3:00 PM, 4:00 PM
wakes up in two, three hours,
same thing again.
Get your hair done,
get your makeup while I'm laughing at him.
Same thing over and over.
- So I guess from what it sounds like,
the lifespan of a host can't
be that long normally, surely.
- Depends on how you conduct yourself.
- Well, if you're in that cycle.
- Of course, not at all.
But this is where Roland
really comes in strong
because he's known to never drink.
- Oh, he has the helpers
with him all the time?
- Yeah, and he's the definition of,
to become a host, you don't have to drink.
All you have to have is
good conversational skills.
And the people who come to the club
only have to come just because
they wanna chat with you.
They wanna gain something out of it.
So he become like a life coach almost.
- Why is it that they have to buy drinks
to like pay the host?
Can you not just give them money?
- I think it's because if
you give someone money,
you're way less likely to
like give someone money.
If you're buying drinks,
it's like feeding the
atmosphere, and you both win.
You're getting the drink you want-
- It's like buying rounds at a pub.
- If I give you a 10,
I'm like (indistinct)
for an hour gone,
I may be like
and looking at the clock every 10 minutes.
But if you finish your drink, I'm like,
you want another drink, Garnt?
You know what I mean?
I think it's because it just
wouldn't get as much money.
- Is that the reason?
- Spot on analysis my friend.
- There you go.
- No, because I maybe compare this to,
like going to a strip club or
something and buying a dance
that is like money being exchanged.
- I'm sure, because I think
it's the same thing, right?
Like I guess for a lot of girls,
getting to talk to a person
is like paying for a service.
Kind of similar as at a
strip club, for example.
- When you're hanging
out with your friends,
if you wanna keep hanging
out, what do you do?
But another drink.
- Buy a round.
- So how much are these drinks marked up?
(all laughing)
(group chattering)
How much are these drinks marked up?
- Everything is about
like times 10 the price.
- I saw a Strong Zero,
like the dead ass bring out the can
and charge you 30 bucks
for it in that one place.
- Yeah, as I said, times
10 of the original price.
- That's not times 10,
that's like times 30.
- And that was chaser,
that was like their water.
The Strong Zero, which is like a 9% drink,
they drunk it like a chaser.
It was like, oh, that drink was so strong.
I'm gonna drink some water,
and it was Strong Zero.
- Yeah, because the one
thing I always know about
the host thing is the
(speaking foreign language)
the champagne towers.
Like how many of those did you have to,
or was that just like,
- Every birthday.
- 'Cause I always thought like...
- How many birthdays did you go to?
- How much is the full one?
Is it just one bottle of Dom Perignon
that you had to pour?
- It depends.
- Or is it like multiple bottles?
- Multiple bottles,
depending on the tower that you've built.
- So, multiple bottles of Dom Perignon,
which are marked up 10 times the price.
- What was it, like $10,000?
- Yeah, I mean, like how much for one
at the club you worked at,
when you got a champagne tower,
how much would a girl have to spend?
If I was a girl and I wanted to buy you
a Dom Perignon champagne tower,
how much would I have to spend?
- So again, this kind of
requires some explaining
because if you're stingy as fuck
and you wanna build like
the smallest tower, you can.
But again, if it's different levels.
- How many glasses there are.
- Exactly, it's all about, showcasing.
The more glasses of tower you have,
the more glamorous it looks.
So even if you're building
half of it with cheap alcohol
and the other half with
actual premium alcohol,
as soon as it looks big enough,
it does the job.
So even if it's someone who has like,
only two, three patreons,
who's only willing to
shell out total maximum,
maybe like $10,000 for your birthday.
(group chattering)
- We're just talking
about like 40% commission
of people earning like
over $50,000 per birthday.
So come on, imagine the
glamorous towers that they build.
- What's the most expensive one?
- What's the most expensive
one you've ever received?
- Or seen?
- Me personally?
- Or what's the most
you've seen someone spend
on one night?
- Bro, I will be proud to tell
this story to the day I die,
but my number one, homie,
he on this one day,
his 30th birthday, he
racked over $200,000...
- What did you do on your 30th birthday?
(all laughing)
- Oh, well, where's my $200,000 boys?
- Bro, I know what I'm
doing for the five years...
- I just hung out with the boys.
They bought me a fucking drink,
it cost like a fucking turner.
Could've got $200,000, what's going on?
- Well, Joey's expectations...
- Finally, another sight of
turning 30, what the fuck.
- So that's, $200,000 is 40%, right?
- So you get to get like...
- Not me, but my homie.
- Yeah, exactly.
And when you're reaching that level,
of course you can still
have champagne towers
that like surround itself.
The trick is to just make
it three dimensional,
so you fill more space.
But you wanna be more
glamorous when you're hosting.
So we hired like a Rolls Royce
at the entrance of the club,
we have like firework kind of stands
at the entrance, make it look
a wedding ceremonial thing.
- You literally got pyrotechnics
when going into the club?
- Bro, it was so much fun though.
- Sounds like the beginning of
like a WWE match or something
(group chattering)
(all laughing)
- But the saddest thing is,
the host can only go on a date
and come to the venue in a
Rolls Royce with only one girl.
(group chattering)
- So you better pick well.
- So the thing is when
you're the number one,
that means you have host
buddies or I mean, sorry,
ladies that are saving up for
your occasion for like months.
After this day, for the
next two, three weeks,
it's all about the conversations.
Like, oh, I saved up for like eight months
and I still couldn't get the position.
It's like oh, my God.
- I guess that makes sense
why the host club you went to
was just like everyone was depressed.
Maybe it was right after a birthday.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Everyone's chasing happiness
and nobody's getting it.
- All the girls are like,
ah, I was, eighth in line.
- Finally, an enemy that
can rival Vici (indistinct)
(all laughing)
- Rewards more.
- Yo, you think these rainbow
super chair's impressive?
- $200,000 Dom Perignon towers.
(all laughing)
Eat your heart out.
- Maybe that's the next thing.
Maybe that's the name VTuber host.
VTuber Kyabakura.
- I guess it is just the same
thing, it's just digitally.
I guess that's what super chats up,
to just get attention from people.
- There's definitely some
of them that are like
organizing one-on-ones
where you can buy time.
- Oh, yeah, of course, of course.
That's the only difference.
- Rarely though.
- Yeah, rarely right now.
Who's your favorite VTuber?
Why are you asking me this, Jan?
- You know, I see you playing some games.
- You like VTubers, Jan?
- I do, I do.
- Who's your favorite?
(group chattering)
- When you get back from the host club
and you're like, all
right, just got like 500...
(group chattering)
- It's like ten ladies come home with you,
it's like ladies, not tonight.
I have a super chat to follow.
- It's like the meme
with the guy on the bed
with four women around him
and he's like there
sending his super channel
There's like six women on me right now,
just wanted to tell you that
you're my favorite VTuber.
It's five bucks.
- Is that how it is?
- Makes sense.
- Who's your favorite then?
- Ahoy.
(speaking in foreign language)
- She was my favorite for a while.
Who's your favorite?
- Why you asking me?
Don't ask me these
questions, don't ask me.
- I feel like I know, but...
- Nah, you don't.
- I know you just (indistinct) about it.
- No, don't bring this up,
don't fucking bring this up.
- If you're listening,
(Joey laughing)
tame your friends.
- Come get your mans.
- Moving on.
(all laughing)
Fuck you, Jan.
- Clippers are just like watching this.
(group chattering)
- Fuck the clippers.
- But I guess like, so you
don't do hosting anymore, right?
- I don't belong to a club anymore.
- Wait, what does that mean?
- It's like a deposition.
It's like, you're not
answering the question
but answering the question.
- You can take the man out of the host,
but not the host out the man.
- I'd beat you, but not part of it.
- Kind of like that.
So basically, you know...
- Wait, you're freelance host?
- Kind of like that
- You've graduated?
- Wait, how the fuck
do you freelance host?
- So, you know,
- Previous clients.
- Since I've been doing this
for almost 10 years now,
the people that I've met along the way
at this point, they're just
there to drink with me,
to get life updates,
because I've known these-
- Like an old friend?
- Yeah.
I've known them for like
almost 10 years, some of them.
I've been invited to weddings and shit,
of the girls that are
getting married, you know?
And I went to some, I shit you not.
- What!
When you spoke to people at
the wedding, how did that go?
Were they like, oh, this
is Jan, this is the guy.
- How did the wife explain to the husband?
- That's what I was gonna ask.
- Bro, so for example,
there was a lady who was back in the day,
she was in her late university time.
And I was telling her, like
you should do exchange,
go to other countries, live life.
- Giving life advice.
- Yeah, exactly.
And then a few years later, you know,
I find out that she's marrying somebody
she met overseas thanks
to her experience abroad.
And then she says she got
to do this just because
I gave her the encouragement to go abroad.
I'm skipping, like the whole arc here
that's the end result here.
- I imagine the husband was like,
you're inviting what?
A host?
- The moment her husband meets me
and then I talk about, the way we met
and the quality conversations we had,
nobody's suspecting anything, you know?
'Cause I'm honest.
- Wait, so did you tell
them that you are a host?
- That's how the wife introduce.
- That's insane.
- The wife's got some balls.
I've never seen someone such
as like big dick energy.
- Hi honey, here's another man
that I spent a lot of
money on before I met you.
But we met because of this man.
- Interestingly, I've heard a lot of that.
Even with my ex-girlfriends
I still see some of them,
- Japan is wack, man.
- With their current boyfriends
and we still hang out and shit.
And that's still the
case with hosting stuff,
like some people that
don't even see me anymore,
just wanna hang out with
their new boyfriends.
- I see what you're writing.
(all laughing)
- We can't say that out loud.
- Are we allowed to ask that?
- [Woman] Can you just
say yes or no to me?
- I mean, you can't hint at it.
- [Woman] Oh, my God.
- That's fucked up, man
(all laughing)
- [Man] That's how it
is, that's how it is.
- For you viewers, the
wedding isn't as innocent
as it seems.
- Listen, I mean, the hosts
are not just for talking.
You can't say that, I
know, I know, I know.
- Elaborate your sentence.
- What are part of the
hosts responsibilities?
- It's not all Disneyland.
(all laughing)
That's what I'm saying.
- It isn't all candys and rainbows.
- Are there more perks to the job,
other than just going on date?
- That's a great question,
if you look at it.
- That's the hardest P I've ever heard.
Perks!
- To answer your question
kind of directly but indirectly,
it involves a lot of mental,
psychological fuckery
Meaning, if you know what somebody wants
and you give it to them straight away,
you might get them to be bored of you.
And then they might
not come back for more.
So the strategy for some
cases is to tease and edge.
But, what are you laughing at, man?
- It's just insane.
- What are you laughing at?
- It's like fucking Barney Stinson
from 'How I Met Your Mother'
(all laughing)
It's insane.
I understand that it's the job, right?
But it's just like psychotic.
- It's one side of it
though, one side of it.
And on the other side,
there are some people that don't want you
for what you're...
- I understand that like,
it's just conversation.
- Yeah, exactly.
They're there just for your company.
So if you push quite on a drunken evening,
you might just ruin your relationship
and then they won't wanna
come back for you again.
So there's a lot that
you have to think about.
And this is with any
other social encounter,
if you think somebody is
beautiful and they're wonderful
and you feel like you wanna
spend a night with them
and they're down for it as well-
'Cause, obviously the only
thing that they pay for
is the drinks.
(group chattering)
- I'm just really enjoying you
trying to explain yourself.
- Listen, I understand, right?
All they pay for is the drinks.
But what you're trying to do
is secure that they keep
coming for those drinks.
You know, you do what you gotta do.
I understand that business is
business and it's ruthless.
And it's childish or
naive as to think that
that is not how the business works.
It doesn't mean I can't
be like, that's fucked up.
- Just to make myself clear,
the way I conduct myself is
with my wits and intelligence
and my unique ability
of talking about shit
that they have no idea about, which is...
- You are a worldly host.
- Yeah, exactly.
Mr. Worldwide, fucking Pitbull.
That's how I do my thing.
But there are some people
that of course push their
physical attributes,
it's like their main selling point.
And they fall into
dilemma where, you know,
if I don't give it to her now
she might not come back next time.
But if I give it to her now,
- She definitely won't
come back next time.
- You know, exactly.
If you're like this and you suck at it,
it's gonna happen.
- I totally get it.
That's just the environment
and the industry
of the host club.
But you know, I'm sure to
a lot of people watching
and some people who are
not versed in this world.
- It seems other worldly.
- For them, it's like what sex, what sex.
- To be fair, I think one
of the most underrated
different aspects of Japanese
culture is the nightlife
and the whole host industry and all that.
People are like, oh, it's so wacky.
They have KFC on Christmas.
It's like, no, bro.
The real weird differences
between the West and here-
- Is the shit that
doesn't get talked about.
- It's the stuff that's
happening at night, man.
It's completely different.
And you know, in some
ways as you come into this
with a foreign perspective
and you judge it as such,
but I feel like in some ways
it's unfair of us to judge
and be like, that's
fucking weird what they do.
It's like, well, I mean,
that's what they do.
That's what they've chosen to do.
And that's how they do the business.
It does sound predatory
at times a little bit,
but I mean, that's my perspective.
- Yeah, I mean, and
again, as you were saying,
it is a thing that,
I think again, Japan is so
good at maintaining a culture.
And like maintaining ways to do a culture,
- The (indistinct) is an ancient artifact.
- Yeah, where sometimes,
they get so encapsulated
in holding onto the
specific cultural thing
that they almost fail to realize that,
you know what, maybe it doesn't
really fit into society,
today's standards.
That's the whole reason why
the fax machines still exist.
- Great point right there.
- They don't realize that,
they just think to themselves,
yeah, it's fucked up,
but this is how it came to be.
This is what makes Japanese
nightlife, Japanese nightlife.
They never stopped to think to themselves,
hey, maybe this fucked up.
Just a bit.
- Although hosts are promoted on TV,
I'm under the impression
that almost on a national level,
it's something that they
try and keep kind of hidden
and that they're not too proud of.
- I guess that is the whole
reason we got Jan on, right?
(group chattering)
- [Jan] To open your eyes.
- So over the past 10 years,
would you say that hosts and
hosts clubs became less popular
or more popular?
- More popular.
- Really?
- Massively.
- Why would you say that?
- Again, thanks to Roland kind of people
who have mainstreamed and showcased
that becoming a host-
- Is it just Roland though?
Or is it maybe because the
whole subculture of host clubs
have just become a little bit more open
to like a general public, maybe?
- What helped to achieve
what you just talked about
is through manga anime.
A lot of these media picked up on that
and then glorified it.
- They make it look like
it's actually fun.
(group chattering)
- It couldn't be further from that.
- You guys know this anime
where there's this guy
who does whatever the
fuck he wants in school
and everybody is like mesmerized by him?
(group chattering)
Crazy bro,
I didn't tell you anything.
- I love Sakamoto.
- Yeah, Connor loves him.
- Exactly that, where
does that derive from?
The core of that principle
comes from the hosting mentality
of being this superior untouchable,
almighty being in the Japanese...
- Meanwhile, they are throwing up
at the Matsuya parking lot,
after they've had a few
one too many drinks,
I mean to pick your point.
- So Sakamoto doesn't show.
- Sakamoto and Jackline steroids.
- The core roots of the
thing, it's the same.
- That's true.
- I agree.
- It's interesting, 'cause
it's just so fucked.
- But it's just kinda crazy to think
that there are people who'd literally
put their life on the line
to like maintain a facade
because that's what gets them the money.
- I mean, it's not the
only Japanese industry
that does that.
You look at the idol industry,
it's entirely based on
like maintaining an image.
- I'd say that's 10 times more toxic, bro.
- You think so?
- Yeah.
- It says a lot when a host says that.
- After everything
you've said to us today.
- I've heard some horror stories.
- I've heard some
absolutely horror stories
which is why I'm like,
I don't even think you're
wrong in saying that
after the stories I've heard.
- My psychology comes from this,
and I think this also relates to,
other idol related industries
that are still popping up to this day,
which is educating your audience.
Your audience is your
main source of income,
at the end of the day.
And within the idol industry,
they're so strict about
everything that females do,
relationship they have with the boys
or any kind of interactions they have.
It's almost toxic.
But why does it even exist?
That's because the industry
standard is bred to be that way.
So you have to educate your own audience
so that you're more
free, you're more open.
You're more willing to accept
radical ideas into your business.
- But no one's willing to
take that risk, are they?
- Well, the companies aren't.
- We're talking about
Asian dudes in suits, bro.
How are you gonna teach
them new tricks, man?
(all laughing)
You're not gonna.
- I get what you're saying.
You just couldn't have said
it in the worst way possible.
- I guess you're Asian, it's okay.
- I'm brutal in the way
I carry myself forward.
- Well, I guess you have to be
to survive as a host at times?
- Generally as a businessman too, bro.
My current job is mostly
about convincing people
to do shit that I want them to.
- Why make it sound so sinister?
- This is one thing I
promised myself not to do
to seem like a sinister,
fucking malicious bastard.
- Well, I mean, the thing is like,
I get what you're saying, right?
Because especially when it
comes to the idol industry
where it's like, industries
don't wanna take a stab
at like a new idea, because again,
it goes back to that whole thing of like
maintaining tradition.
This is how we've been doing it,
it's been working so far, let's do it.
Idols can't say anything
because the moment they, like,
'I have a radical idea' they're like
'All right, see you later, bye bye.'
- Say bye to your career.
- Say goodbye.
And then if a fan says,
"Uh, hey, maybe this is kind of fucked up,
then the community gets
on his ass and goes like,
"Get the fuck out then."
So it's like, no one wins.
There's no space for
change until, as you said,
like at the end of the day,
you need to get the entirety to be like,
oh yeah, this is fucked,
and maybe we should change it.
- And that change is over time.
It can't be something
that's done overnight.
But like at the same time,
who's gonna take that first step.
'Cause that's a massive risk.
- The pioneers of the business bro,
in whatever format that is,
whether it's, you know...
- You think they wanna risk everything
that they've built up
over time for just like...
They're not gonna wanna do that.
That's the issue.
That is unfortunately the issue.
- Unless you have
someone like super smart,
again, like Roland, right?
I guess he's a great example.
- It takes a fucking person like Roland
to really shake things up.
- The example I wanna
give here is from Naruto.
(all laughing)
- Are you serious?
- If you say believe it,
I will actually smack you.
- You did not just dead
ass look me in the face
and say that Jan.
- Do tell.
- Don't lose hope on me yet, bro.
- Explain yourself.
- You guys know Hitachi, right?
- Yes, we know Hitachi.
- (laughs) Where are you going?
- Where are you going with Hitachi?
- Well, spoilers.
- You're trying to spoil it too much.
- If you haven't watched Naruto yet,
after all this time, fuck you, honestly.
- I haven't watched Naruto.
- What!
- You guys know I haven't watched Naruto.
- No, we don't.
- What!
- How did you pop off on YouTube?
(all laughing)
by not watching Naruto?
What did you do?
- You know what I do.
- You give me hope, bro.
(all laughing)
- Why me?
- You give me hope that in five years,
maybe I can be like you.
- Why do you wanna be like me?
- Well, now you can't
because you've seen Naruto.
You have no chance.
- Okay, so come on tell
us about Naruto then.
- He has no interest in
ever watching Naruto.
- Yeah, he's not gonna care.
- I'm gonna watch it.
- Can you guys refresh me
on what the main topic
of the argument was?
- You were about to give some life advice
concerning Hitachi.
- And Naruto.
- But why though?
- Pioneer or something,
you are quite drunk.
You finished the whole of this bottle.
- Guys, please be sure.
Unless I get to this point
(Joey laughing)
sober as daylight.
- Tell us the story.
- So basically, Hitachi
sacrificed his whole life being
for the greater good that he believed in.
A shoe he had to fill in,
at an age that even he
had no understanding
or conscious about.
- Okay.
(Connor laughing)
- Stop laughing, bitch.
- Go on, go on, go on.
(Jan laughing)
- Stop laughing, bitch.
(all laughing)
- It's so hard to sound smart
when you're talking about Hitachi.
(all laughing)
- That's why we laugh.
- That's why we're laughing, bro.
- You had countless historical figures
who've sacrificed their
entire existence for a course.
And out of all of them,
you chose fucking Hitachi from Naruto?
- He's a very well suited though.
- Well go on then, go on, make your point.
- Was there a point? (laughs)
- He sacrificed himself for
the greater good of the family.
- What was the main point, bro?
- I don't fucking know.
You are the one who
was like, bro, Hitachi,
Hitachi though, pioneer.
- We were talking about pioneers
who shake up the industry,
- Who sacrificed everything.
- And then you said Hitachi
sacrificed his entire life.
- All right, exactly.
For example, in the Narutoverse,
if Hitachi didn't do what he did,
nobody would have come
to the realization of,
the whole,
the dilemma of following the past
and continuing the path you do
leading to the same outcome.
- Continuing the lineage, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
'Cause you know the whole Sasuke people
and the Naruto Uzumaki people.
- I'm sorry to interrupt,
I just have this-
- You're talking about the Uchiha clan?
- The woman sitting down
the football stadium,
the guy is like.
This is him at the host club
(group chattering)
- He's talking about how he was,
like you need life experience, he's like,
"So Naruto, right, bro, you
won't believe it, right.
So when he had the sand thing,
he took off the weights,
it was insane, bro.
He took them off and he just...
Bro, it changed history."
Okay, buy me a drink.
- Is this what you've
been telling the girls?
Just talking about Naruto?
- Ah, no.
- So you were saying,
so he sacrifices himself for
the good of the Uchiha family.
- Exactly, and for the greater good,
not even Uchiha family alone.
- [Man] Clan.
- 'Cause he knew...
- The clan, yeah.
- I like Sasuke people.
(group chattering)
- I'm sorry, I'm so sorry.
- He clearly loves Naruto.
- I do though, honestly.
I fucking read the manga, did you?
You didn't, fuck you.
So that's what I considered
the core media mass, manga.
If you haven't read the manga
and you just watched the anime
you ain't a true fan.
- Okay.
- In my book.
So to those people who watch basak anime
and don't read the manga and
you call yourself a super fan,
you better don't.
(group chatter)
- What happened to the life advice?
- The life advice here is that,
so if Hitachi didn't take the path he did,
we would have never reached
the conclusion that,
(speaking foreign language)
coming to get her to understand each other
would be the solution.
I know it's such a cheesy shit
and Naruto gives you that.
But at the end of the day,
that's what it came down to.
Hitachi going to break that path.
- Listen idol companies.
- So what you're saying is
every industry needs an Hitachi?
- Exactly, exactly.
You might sacrifice
yourself, your own being,
your own career,
but it's for the greater
good of reaching, you know...
(all clapping)
- A beautiful speech.
Thanks for coming to his Ted talk.
- Hitachi, yeah.
Buy him a drink now.
You have to buy him a drink now.
We all have to buy you a drink
now for that life advice.
- Not a champagne tower.
- We'll buy you a normal
drink at a normal bar.
- I'm waiting for you
guys at my next birthday.
(all laughing)
- Hypothetically...
- Me and Garnt will be kicked out.
(group chattering)
- Fortunately, it's only Joey.
- Fuck!
(all laughing)
- Hypothetically though,
would you even accept if
I did actually buy you
a champagne tower?
- Fuck yeah, bro.
- Okay.
(all laughing)
I thought you were gonna be like a bro
and be like, no, no, no, you're my-
- The way you shook your head,
he was just like, fuck yeah, bro.
- Fuck our friendship.
- He wouldn't even consider it.
- 'Cause that happens a lot actually.
- What?
- Like the homies inviting
their other homies.
- To boost your numbers?
- Not just to boost your
numbers but to drink with you.
As I said, a lot of the
most successful host,
- [Connor] Bro, this woman
is boring as fuck, bro,
come over and help me.
- That's the case 'cause as I
said, most successful hosts,
they're so busy in the evening that like,
even if you're a good homies,
you don't get to drink with that guy.
So sometimes you're like,
bro, enough is enough
I wanna drink with you.
I'm going with your club,
and you're like,
"Yeah, sure bro, just pay
a price and come over."
- This is like min maxing.
Min maxing social interaction.
- I get to hang out with
my bros and I get paid.
- Exactly, but you use
the money they pay you
that gets into your pocket, you kind of...
- Give it back to them.
- In the next drinking
that will come,
- You pay for them.
- Yeah, exactly.
Come on, you can't be
a total social asshole.
- So what you're saying is if I bought you
a Dom Perignon champagne
tower for your birthday,
you will happily say hell yeah,
but then you'd buy me drinks.
- On your birthday, I'll
fucking light it up, bro.
- He's gonna be paying you
back for the rest of the time.
I don't even wanna know how much that is.
- They probably go for
more than $10,000, right?
Maybe six digits, 100,000, some places.
- Are we talking JPY or dollars?
- Dollars.
- Six digits?
- Yeah.
- That's (indistinct) kind of shit, bro.
- So it exists.
- It does exist.
- Oh my God.
Could you imagine spending
$100,000 on a dude
for his birthday?
- I can't even imagine spending $100,000.
- Yeah, right.
(all laughing)
I mean like a house that you're
investing in or something.
- Imagine you're the
daughter of a billionaire,
then what are you gonna do?
Your life is all about spending money,
waiting to marry the right guy.
- That's a totally different world.
- We're not the daughter of a billionaire.
- I know, I know.
But I'm just giving you a perspective.
- [Connor] In another life maybe.
- In another life, yeah.
- Other life indeed.
- So your starting a Twitch, right?
- Oh yeah, I am indeed.
- And you're finally gonna
have an internet presence.
- Yap, indeed.
Finally, hopefully.
- We've focused on the host aspect,
but Jan has a lot of varied stories
and a lot of aspects in your life.
He's not just an ex host or ex host.
- Freelance hosts now.
- You've done a lot of shit.
And we've been trying to convince him
for the longest time
to start an IRL stream,
or whatever you wanna stream.
- I mean, hopefully
this Trash Taste episode
has proven that Jan has the chops
to be a really interesting
internet personality.
- You're a character.
- You are such a character.
- Sometimes, I just need to give you a mic
and just let you talk and just like.
(all laughing)
- I hope so, man.
- So you're starting a stream, right?
Or Twitch?
- Indeed.
Sushikebab, check it out on Twitch.
- What are you gonna do?
Just play games or like do viral stuff or?
- I'm not planning on,
I don't really wanna play games.
So what I have planned is,
every Sunday I wanna do something called
Controversial Sundays,
(Joey laughing)
where I test the limits of Twitch
and see how much it's gonna-
- Bro, you're gonna be
banned so damn fast.
- How much is it gonna take
for me to be banned on Twitch?
That's what I wanna do, every Sunday.
- You're doing a Twitch ban speed run?
- If I do get banned for
the fucks of it, why not?
- What are you gonna
do, get your dick out?
- What do we have to lose?
I just wanna have fun on Twitch, bro.
- Bro, they're gonna ban
you before you start it.
- Yeah, why are we
promoting a Twitch channel
that might get banned?
- So we can all have fun together.
- [Connor] Oh, my God.
- Look, so all I wanna do is talk about
really fucked up subjects on Sundays.
Get my take, if I can
get any of your takes,
that'll be great, but if
you don't wanna do it-
- No, no, no, you're
not getting our takes.
- I ain't going near this.
- I'm not sacrificing my
career for you Jan, I'm sorry.
- But by suckling on this
sweet tits of social clout
that I'm getting from you guys,
hopefully I can get
other smaller time people
who wanna call out with
me to just talk about
some fucked up subject on Sundays.
That'll be great.
- Maybe you should,
I think it's like X hamster...
- Yeah, xx videos is another good website.
- [Connor] You can livestream there.
- I heard chaturbate has a
really good streaming site.
- You can talk about whatever
the fuck you want there
and not get banned for sure.
- Live leak is pretty good too.
- Yeah, live leak, that's a great one.
- I mean, how fucked are we talking?
I don't know, Jan.
- I was expecting like
a nice, warm welcome.
(all laughing)
- When you were like,
hey guys, I wanna start Twitch channel.
In my head, I was like, oh yeah, you know.
- You said you bought a PS5 for it.
- He's gonna play some games
like any other person on Twitch.
Bro, as I mentioned,
to be host you have to
distinguish yourself
This is how I wanna distinguish myself.
- So you're gonna just go
say the N word on livestream.
- No, holy fuck, is that
how your brain functions?
(all laughing)
- I literally don't know.
- You said you're gonna try your hardest
to get banned on Twitch
- No, I'm gonna try my hardest
to go towards the edge of
getting banned and not banned.
- I guess like one question to wrap up
this whole host club thing is,
because you said that the
host club side of things
has grown massively in
the past five, ten years.
whether that be because of
Roland or not, you know,
is off the debate.
But like as someone who
again, used to be in that
and is no longer at it any more
where do you see it going
in the next five, ten years?
Will it become more mainstream,
or as mainstream as it can be?
Or will it just be like
forever this subculture thing?
- Difficult question
because as you mentioned,
Roland had a huge impact on the industry.
He bought it to the mainstream.
But due to the current
unfortunate situation
that's threatening the whole world,
the intimacy of host
clubs are really limited.
You have to wear masks
and you have to have like
face barriers and stuff.
- Not very romantic.
- Yeah, a lot of people are kind of not so
incentivized to go to these clubs anymore.
- The whole Kabukicho nightlife area
just got absolutely
fucked because of rona.
- So that is a huge obstacle.
But a lot of places are
finding their way around it.
Whether by doing like streams actually,
so host club streams.
- [Connor] Where?
- Where?
- On like Twitch and stuff or?
- On YouTube or...
- On YouTube?
- Will you send us some links later?
- Yeah, I wanna see these.
- Sure, bro.
So people are doing their own.
But mostly like individual
hosts are doing their own thing
because they do know that
building your own brand
is more important than
building the company's brand.
Kind of like following
in Roland's footstep.
I'm really glamoring this guy,
but he really, really had a huge impact
on the whole industry.
The way he just brought in
ideas and showcase the world,
that the way he wants to do his business
can actually viable.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- That's a very good answer.
- Really left on a somber note.
- On that note, go check him
out on all of his socials.
- Just kind of trailed off.
- There's a huge potential
in the future though.
It's not gonna dwindle away.
- No, I don't think so.
- That's for a fact.
- But yeah, thanks for coming on, Jan.
- This has been a wild ride.
- This has been a very
interesting episode.
- Especially the past ten minutes, huh.
- But like where can people
find you on Twitch, right?
What's your username on Twitch?
- On Twitch, Twitter...
- Or is it all the same
on Twitch and Twitter?
- Twitch, Twitter, Instagram,
what's the other one that
(indistinct) people use?
- [Garnt] YouTube?
- Facebook?
- YouTube, fuck.
- Yeah, everything is sushikebabguy.
- Sushikebab.
- Sushi kebab.
'Cause when you say, it's like sushkebab.
- Sushi kebab, the reason,
half Japanese, half Turkish.
- And you're a guy.
- And I'm a guy.
So sushi kebab guy,
you can't miss it.
(Joey laughing)
- All right, go check him out.
I guess, link is in the description
and look at all his patreons.
So many of them, look at all of them.
Who's your favorite?
- That guy right there.
- Who would you buy a drink for?
No one, you buy them a drink.
- Who deserves the champagne tower?
- Anyone that has a name
that starts with A and X.
- Why?
- Why not,
just a random thought.
(all laughing)
- Well, hopefully there's an Ax out there.
- Ax is like, yeah!
- You deserve a huge
hug and a kiss from me.
- Mind you, he has finished
a half a bottle of gin.
- By myself 'cause these pussy ass bitches
didn't wanna drink with me.
(all laughing)
- Jesus Christ.
- Thanks guys for joining us.
- Yeah, if you wanna support the show,
make sure to go to our page
on patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit
and if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
Go check out Jan and
thanks for coming, dude.
- Thank you, bro.
- [Garnt] Thank you
very much for coming on.
- Pleasure, pleasure.
- Thank you for having me, man
- Come here, man.
- A pleasure, pleasure.
- Pleasure doing business with you.
God, you're hands are so fine.
- What the fuck.
- Yeah, I know, I know.
Can I stick it in this too?
'Cause you promised this,
when this episode is coming out,
or right after it comes out,
me and Connor, we'll be doing
a react episode on Twitch.
- Oh, we are gonna do a reactor?
- Yes.
- All right.
I guess we'll react to
it, we'll react to it.
- Oh, my God, all right.
Thanks for watching guys,
we'll see you in the next one.
Bye.
- Bye.
(bright upbeat music)